Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my gosh, I need a little bit right now.
I need a little bit to like, rev up my system at the moment.
My eyes... I just feel like a little bit fatigued today.
So I just need like a little...
It usually takes me a while to get back into the groove of things.
I just need a little bit...
Need a little bit of time to just be like...
Like a little car engine right now.
We looped because I have to wash my cup.
Because I need a tea today.
Just a little bit of caffeine today.
But I am okay.
I am okay.
Update.
My team won Twitch Rivals.
We beat Shroud and xQc.
That's... I don't really want to say more.
I don't really want to say more because I'm done with drama.
I'm just...
I'm happy we won.
I'm very happy.
I...
Like legitimately, I can't believe like...
I got out...
Like I stayed...
Like, you know, I ventured out of the YouTube bubble.
For...
For two weeks.
And then got into this whole situation.
But in the end, it doesn't matter.
Because my team ended up winning.
We won the...
We won Twitch Rivals.
Cody's planning on releasing a video.
So check that out.
I saw the script.
He sent me the script.
And was like, can I say this?
Are you comfortable with me saying this?
And I was like...
Yeah, you know I'm a neighborly.
So fucking yeah, let's do it.
Like...
I was like...
Yeah, keep that shit in.
Do it.
Keep that shit in.
I don't care.
So when you watch the video...
It's gonna be fucking spicy.
That's for sure.
It's gonna be...
Okay.
I'll say something.
I think it's...
Okay.
Cody...
He's also an enabler.
And I fucking love Cody.
He's so...
Oh my god.
He does not care.
He's also an enabler.
And he would like...
He's willing to argue with anybody.
Even children.
So...
You know...
There were some people that were not happy about our team winning.
And then they kept like spamming on Twitter.
On all of us.
And so like...
Cody...
I messaged Cody.
And he was like...
He was like...
Oh yeah.
That shit was so fun.
I had an hour to kill while my kid was at gym...
While my kid was at gymnastic practice.
And it fucking feels me.
And I was like...
I was like...
My man.
And he was like...
Yeah.
I just had an hour to kill.
And I figured...
Might as well.
Nothing else to do right now.
And then...
So like...
At one point...
A weather bot was...
Like...
It was...
Okay.
I thought it was so fucking funny.
But like...
There is one account that he was arguing with.
That was a gimmick account.
It was a weather bot...
Slash...
XQC fan account.
I was like...
What a crazy combination.
And then...
Cody was like...
Oh my god.
I'm arguing with a weather bot.
It was so funny.
Because I was like...
What the fuck?
How are you like...
What a combo.
So...
So yeah.
It was...
Such a fucking Twitter moment right there.
I don't know how people can thrive off of...
Like...
I understand like...
That's how you can build up momentum.
And like how you can...
How you can like...
Create like...
Like how...
What's the word?
How you put yourself on people's feed.
Because it makes people remember you and stuff like that.
Because it's like...
You know...
Doing drama and like...
Being involved and shit like that.
It raises engagement.
It puts you on...
It makes people be aware of you.
Visibility.
All of that.
Stay in the dialogue.
It makes you relevant.
But that shit is so tired.
I don't understand.
Like I...
I was like...
I don't understand how people can do this.
It's like...
Like I'm just like...
I...
I was so tired.
Like I was so...
I wasn't even like involved anymore.
But I was so tired.
But...
I gained 3k followers on Twitter.
Which was crazy.
Because I was like...
I didn't do anything.
I literally just...
I made two tweets.
Just to clarify.
That I wasn't gonna be there.
And like explaining to my fans.
Why I won't be there.
And then I gained 3k Twitter followers.
From...
I don't even know how many like Twitch followers I gained from that.
I gained like...
I'm so surprised.
Because like...
I barely exist on Twitter.
And...
And like...
And then like people were like...
You know what?
I'm a follower after this.
I'm like...
Oh my god.
I think like the funniest part though.
During the entire Twitch Rivals tournament.
Is that...
Every time they win a game.
Or before they get into a game.
Or they win anything.
My...
Old team...
Would be like...
For Doki!
And then people have no idea what the fuck is going on.
Because the team wasn't named Doki anymore.
It was named Hogs.
Like after like...
Like my replacement captain.
People were like...
Who the fuck is Doki?
I'm like...
Please say Doki Bird.
Please for the love of god.
Someone just say Doki Bird.
Because I don't want them to follow that Rainbow Six Siege guy.
That has the name Doki right now.
Like...
I was like...
Please.
Someone say Doki Bird.
Or everything's gonna funnel to that random Rainbow Six Siege pro player.
Who has the name Doki.
Please.
I...
For Doki called Rainbow Six Siege.
Nestor.
If you look it up on Twitch.
This guy has...
I could never change my name.
Because like...
I always wanted to be Doki.
Like just straight up Doki for Twitch.
Because I thought I was so clean.
But like...
This guy has claimed the name Doki for like...
Years now.
I think like 6 plus years.
Ever since Rainbow Six Siege was a thing.
So like...
If anybody's gonna look up Doki on Twitch.
That guy's name is gonna show up.
And I'm like...
Someone say Doki Bird.
Please.
It's not that.
Someone
say Doki Bird.
I don't wanna funnel everybody into this random guy's channel.
No one knew.
Doki Bird is not the...
Is the real not Doki.
We're too late.
For not Doki.
Gets the free advertisement.
Basically.
Yeah.
Anyway.
I don't know who we're for anymore.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How does it feel knowing that Coney is a Mutant and Raccoon lover?
I think the most terrible thing is that my team won because they had to put Coney on Rocket Raccoon.
And that was like the game changing strat.
And it really...
It really hurt.
It really did.
I...
I got...
I did get a little sad.
That...
The reason why we won was because we put Coney on Rocket Raccoon.
And it does...
It does make me a little sad after my prejudice against Raccoon.
They won because of a fucking Raccoon.
If I was there, this would never have happened.
Guys, if I was there, this would have never happened.
My favorite was every time Coney's chat convinced him to go Mr. Fantastic.
His entire chat would just say that again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Paladins, thank you for the super chat.
The team won it for you, Coach Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
GoldenDragon, thank you for the super chat.
Congratulations on your team winning Twitch Rivals.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Testidious, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone got what they deserved, including your team's win.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's been a wild couple of days.
I'll talk a little bit more about it, but basically...
I know I said I was not going to talk more, but like...
Fuck it.
I'm already...
I lied.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Basically, uh...
I am...
I'm also like really tired.
I'm still like waiting for the...
The...
The caffeine to kick in right now.
But like, I...
I didn't get...
I didn't play in the tournament, but like, I was so scared and nervous.
Like, I legitimately...
I talked about it on the Kony stream when the tournament ended.
But like, I was actually so anxious and like so...
So nervous that I didn't even do any work yesterday.
I know I was like, I'm not going to watch it.
But like, I watched the quarterfin...
The...
I watched the semis and the finals because I was...
You know, they were literally playing Shroud and xQc.
And like, I was so nervous for them.
And like, I didn't care.
My main goal was to...
I wanted them to beat Shroud.
Because I live vicariously through them.
I'm like the dance mom because I couldn't meet my goals.
So I...
I pretended that I was them.
And like...
I lived through their lives.
And...
And like...
So like, I legitimately did not care if we lose or win against xQc.
I just really wanted them to beat Shroud.
So...
So I was so scared because I thought it was...
Like, the first two games...
It was very scared.
And then like...
I couldn't watch on the third game.
After the third game, I stopped watching.
Because I was legitimately gonna throw up.
I...
That was how nervous and anxious I was.
I was...
I legitimately was gonna throw up if I kept watching.
And so like, I...
Like, I messaged Boger.
And I was like, are you watching the games?
And he was like, yeah.
And then I was like...
Oh my god.
Like, can you like, tell me if they win or not?
Because I can't take this.
They're making this way too close for me.
Like, I...
Like, I was like...
I can't.
They legitimately...
They won by like, 1%.
They could've...
It was so scary.
Because Shroud was winning the last...
Very last match.
And then they flipped it.
It was King of the Hill.
And they flipped it at the very last game.
And from 99...
From 0 to 99 to 100 to 99.
It was the 1% flip.
And it...
I...
I like...
Oh my god.
I legitimately...
I was gonna...
I was gonna throw up.
Because like, I watched the last game.
During the last game.
I watched it.
And I was gonna be like...
Alright, I'm either gonna be super fucking depressed.
Or...
I'm gonna...
Okay, it was like...
I'm gonna be...
Okay, so like...
Kony was like...
Has like a fucking nuclear bomb.
And he was like...
If I lose this, this goes off.
There's gonna be some mutual assured destruction.
And I was like...
Oh man, if we lose this...
We're gonna be here for...
More shit's gonna come.
And he was like...
I'm gonna break glass in case of emergency.
He was ready to say something.
And we didn't lose.
So I was like...
Oh thank god we won.
Thank god we can move on.
I was like...
Oh thank god.
We can move on.
And we win this.
And then...
And then like...
XQC was just like...
A fucking desert after that.
Like I didn't care.
I was alright after.
He was like...
I'm ready to burn all...
No, Kony was like...
I'm ready to burn all the bridges.
I was like...
Oh my god, Kony.
You shouldn't ask me for my push mission.
You know I'm an enabler.
I was like...
You know I'm a fucking enabler.
I'm not stopping you.
I'm not stopping you, Kony.
You know that.
But yeah, look forward to the video, fam.
Look forward to the video.
Whenever he uploads it.
I saw the script and I was like...
Oh my god.
Yeah, you see.
He was ready.
He was ready to burn everything.
Like burn every bridge.
I wasn't scared about the XQC match.
I was a little scared because I was like...
Why the fuck did you guys have to make it that close at the last game?
Like the last two games.
I was like...
You guys did not have to make it that close, guys.
I got a little scared when they lost the third game.
They lost the third game.
I was like...
Guys, come on.
Just pack it up.
I'm fucking tired.
I'm so tired.
But I'm glad.
But the content...
I'm really proud of my...
I'm really proud of my team.
And I'm proud of how well they did in the end.
Like a lot of them are now...
They're on a lot of people's radars.
I heard like...
Hogs and Gomez were both like...
Praised by a lot of giant content creators.
Like Tariq and Shroud.
They were spectating Gomez and Hogs.
And they were like...
They were like...
These guys are actually really cracked out.
And people crashing out over our 17-year-old kid.
17-year-old kid.
I'm like...
Bro,
she's 17, man.
Why are you crashing out on her?
You have legitimately years of experience.
And an insane career.
She literally made...
She made...
This has been the most money she's ever made in anything.
Like, come on, bro.
And she was playing with a broken mouse, man.
Bro, okay.
The craziest thing is that...
I don't think people realize.
She was playing Cloak and Dagger.
Cloak and Dagger, right now...
Is one of the easiest characters to play in Marvel Rivals.
At high ELO.
Because she doesn't require aim.
It's all just a mental warfare.
Cloak and Dagger is all about positioning and mental warfare.
That's really it.
It's just chess, playing Cloak and Dagger.
So, it's like...
Of course, it's super easy to pick up on.
And that's legitimately all she was grinding.
And she was getting coached by good players, too.
During the last week.
So I'm like, are you really complaining about...
A Cloak and Dagger player?
Are you really gonna complain about a Cloak and Dagger player?
Like...
If anything, you should complain about the people who were playing aim-intensive characters.
But were doing as well as a one-and-above-all player.
That's what you should be complaining about.
Not a fucking Cloak and Dagger.
That's crazy.
Anyway...
The tournament's over now.
Everybody's gonna forget about the drama and all that shit within literally the next week or so.
And especially certain fans are just gonna move on to the next drama that's most likely to happen maybe tomorrow.
No, Doki!
No, you're just giving them more ammo!
You're just gonna put more of a target on you!
I'm on YouTube, like...
I'd be surprised if they ever venture out of Twitch.
Like, at best, they'll, like, fucking try to get me on Twitter.
But I'd be surprised if they ever venture here.
Yeah, and...
At best, I'm just gonna see the same two guys that's spamming Twitter about this.
Like, the fact that it's just...
Literally just one or two guys just...
Oh yeah, except for there's one guy that's everywhere that's been copy and pasting the same thing over and over on, like, multiple videos.
But he can't do it here because I already, like, banned him.
Because I was like, bro, what the fuck are you doing here?
Go back to Twitter.
I literally just instantly, like, hid his name.
Because, like...
Okay, the funniest thing is that he sees his own comments.
So he doesn't know he's banned.
Because there's, like, a function in YouTube where you just, like, hide user from this channel.
But, like, he'll see his own comments.
But, like, he won't know that he's banned.
Like, he won't...
Yeah.
He won't know.
So he'll just keep posting and being like, I got her now.
I got her now.
That's yelling into the void.
Yeah, so yeah, that was the...
That's the life update.
That was the life update regarding Marvel Rivals.
I'm really...
Like I said, I'm really happy.
I'm really happy with how well my team did.
And I hope that they have a great career right after.
I hope that a lot of them do really well with the new attention on them.
I heard that, like, Shroud was potentially looking at, like, Gomez and Hogs.
And, like, their performances and their team because of how well they were doing during this.
So I hope that leads to more paths for the rest of my team.
And then now everybody knows that Sabuku is, like, a fucking prodigy.
Like, being 17 and able to, like, you know, like, piss off some of the biggest content creators out there.
Like, crying over a 17-year-old kid.
Like, a 17-year-old girl, too.
And, like, you know, Coney being fucking Coney.
And then there's Ms. Rock and Jaboni having people's eyes on them.
And, yeah, it's been a great... I'm really happy and proud of my team.
And, like, that's really all I wanted to update you on about Marble Rivals.
I actually haven't played Marble Rivals in a long time... in a while now.
I think for a couple of days ever since, like, the Twitch Rivals stuff happened.
I was also, like, incredibly busy, too.
And I was honestly, like, super busy.
It's not like I'm like, I HATE MARBLE RIVALS!
I was just really busy in between no date times.
Other than that, another life update.
The schedule is late because I am confirming a collab with someone.
And, like, she's really, really busy yet.
So, like, I don't know... I don't know if we're doing it this week.
But, like, I might post... I might just postpone it to next week.
Because, like, she's been really, really busy.
So, her on Discord, it's like she doesn't show up on Discord often.
So, it might be, like, next week or so.
So, if I don't get a reply by...
Like, whenever she replies back...
Whenever she replies back, I'm asleep or, like, I'm busy.
So, like, and then when I reply back, she's asleep or, like, she's busy.
So...
So, it's like...
It's, like, always this weird back and forth.
So, that's why, like, I couldn't... I couldn't, like, get it confirmed.
So, if... I'm gonna post a schedule by tonight.
If I don't hear anything back or we couldn't arrange anything for this week...
I'm just gonna post it by tonight.
And so, tomorrow, I'll be doing Toraba.
And...
Okay, let me look at my schedule again.
I... Honestly, I forgot what I'm doing.
I'll be doing Toraba at 12.30 tomorrow.
And I'll be doing a member's watch-along of Borderlands the movie.
Because it's now $4 to rent it.
No!
Like, I'll be like...
Yay!
And then be like...
No!
It's now... You can now rent that movie, guys.
For $4.
So, you know what that means, everybody.
We're gonna be watching Borderlands.
We're gonna...
Good luck.
Come on, guys.
You know it'll be fun.
Come on, everybody.
Come on.
Don't you wanna watch Borderlands?
Come on, guys.
Join us.
The non-member goons are like...
Finally.
We're free.
The non-member goons are like...
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
I'm not a member.
And then Felia is like...
No, you're coming in here.
No, you're...
Felia, thank you for the five gifted chips.
He's like...
No, you're coming.
You're coming in here.
You're suffering with...
No, wait.
Wait.
Guys, being a member dragoon is both a curse and a blessing.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Many gifted...
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
He's like...
That's right.
Get in here, dragoons.
Get your ass in here.
We're all going to be watching.
We're all going to be watching Borderlands.
JohnnyLeCone, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Mac, thank you with the five gifted chips.
All right.
Anyway, so that is...
That is the current...
Oh, it's a bite size.
Bite size and blazing.
Thank you for the five and 20 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
But yes, that is the...
That is the schedule for tomorrow.
And then, I don't know about the rest for now.
Because everything is up in the air for now.
Regarding what I'm going to be doing.
Depending on if the collab is confirmed for this week or next week.
Originally, she asked for Sunday.
But I usually don't stream on Sunday.
And I feel weird to put it on Sunday.
Because I just feel like...
Since my schedule...
Usually, I don't post my schedule early.
So, I was like...
I feel better if people can prepare for it and stuff like that.
So, it's either going to be this week or next week.
So, I'm not sure.
Who is this collab with?
I don't want to confirm anything yet.
Because I don't want to be like...
People are going to start pressuring stuff and things like that.
So, no.
Not going to leak it this time.
I'm not leaking who I'm collabing with.
You'll see if it's confirmed.
You'll see.
Stuff Sharky.
Neppers.
MrBrokenBond.
Thank you for the 5 and 10 gifted chips.
I like how Akachi just joined on their own free will.
This guy was like...
Oh my god.
I can finally watch my favorite movie.
Borderlands.
This guy.
This guy actually joined on his own free will.
He was like...
Oh my god.
I'm so excited, guys.
Finally, I can actually use this membership.
And watch something I've been waiting for forever.
This was the moment that made them subscribe.
That made them join the tomato farm.
They're like...
Say less.
We're watching Borderlands.
Say fucking less.
The one Borderlands fan is him.
Say less, queen.
I would...
There was nothing else that wanted me to join the membership until today.
This is the strongest Borderlands fan.
Mike and Duck.
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you for the 5 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Odin, thank you for the super chat.
Now is that we don't stop her next...
Oh, you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's so cute that you think we didn't watch Assassin's Creed.
That's so cute.
We watched it all.
Oh, JK.
You think...
You think we didn't...
If you think of a bad movie...
We watched it.
We fucking watched it.
Alright.
Alright, we're actually playing Dynasty Warriors now.
Sorry for the long delay.
We're finally gonna play Dynasty Warriors.
I'm super excited.
It might be a longer stream than usual.
Because I found out this game is like 25 to 30 hours long.
That's...
I was like, oh man, I might have...
We went from one super long series to the next super long series.
So we're gonna be here for a bit.
I didn't realize, guys.
I didn't realize how long the series is.
Okay, so thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Okay, I didn't even remember how to play.
But yeah, I wanna do a long stream today.
I feel like we've been doing a lot of like...
Oh my god, I forgot.
Spikes hurt.
I've been doing like a lot of like super long game series though.
I noticed that.
Okay, I didn't remember how to fight, guys.
I actually forgot.
Okay, which is bad.
Oh shit, I...
Freedom!
I didn't forget about that though.
Okay.
Alright, we figured that out.
Alright, I just killed the eight foot fucking god right there.
Meow.
Honestly, my favorite feature.
Alright, we're gonna...
Like my whole mission is to get to Lu Bu.
That's really it, honestly.
That is my entire mission.
We are here to kill Lu Bu.
We shall pursue Lu Bu.
Don't worry, me, a guy that was written out of history.
I can take him.
I know I can.
Wait, where did he go?
Did I kill him?
Oh my god, I faced the wrong direction.
I...
I actually faced the wrong...
Are you fucking serious?
I faced the wrong direction with my Musou.
Okay, people who don't pursue Lu Bu are fucking...
Are fucking betas, dude.
Nice.
I parried.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
You can't kill Lu Bu.
You might as well revoke your...
You might as well uninstall Dynasty War...
You're not a Dynasty Warrior gamer if you don't pursue Lu Bu.
Did I not kill all of them?
Yeah, and now I win.
I thought I killed all of them.
Oh my god, what is my actual mission?
What?
Okay, okay.
Next up, this area.
Exactly.
You know what I heard?
Okay, so you know how I'm saying like everybody in this game is now super handsome?
So, what I heard...
Is that they made...
Oh, what's his name?
I always forget his name because I don't give a fuck about him.
And like, I hate him as a character and a historical figure.
But the...
What was his name?
It's the...
It's like, it's Lu Bu's...
It's Lu Bu's leader.
What's his name?
I hate him as everything.
Dong...
Yeah, Dong Zhuo.
Dong Zhao.
I don't fucking know how to pronounce him.
I don't even care about him.
They made him handsome too.
And I'm like, he is known in history to be the ugliest, fattest motherfucker.
Like...
I was like, no way.
They made him handsome?
Yeah, no.
Okay, we're gonna see him.
I didn't see any pictures of it yet.
But people were like, oh, I can't wait for her.
I can't wait for her to see him.
No, everybody actually got a glow up.
It's crazy.
He's like, skinnier too.
He was known to be like, fat and ugly.
But with a very hot wife.
Who gets like, stolen by Lu Bu.
But like, so...
Historically inaccurate.
He was known to be fat and ugly.
And like, and evil.
But then they like, be like...
This game was like, okay.
But what if he's misunderstood?
I'm like, I don't want him to be misunderstood!
I don't...
I don't want him to be misunderstood.
They just like me.
But Doki, these are his origins.
Oh, I can have accessories now.
You can select which to equip on equipment.
Oh, battle arts.
Oh, okay.
Wait, do I have upgrades for it now?
I can do whirlwind kick.
Nice.
It's because you never know him after he hit puberty.
Brabs, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't want him to be misunderstood!
I want to hate him!
I don't care!
He's a terrible person.
Gracias, Doki.
Gracious, gracias, Doki.
Please let us watch a good movie like the...
Dark Blade.
That's so cute that you think we're ever gonna watch a good movie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Kaz!
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, wait, that's just free stuff.
Do I have anything?
No, okay.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I should travel to this period of ancient China to become handsome, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Kaz, thank you, thank you.
We will kill...
We will pursue Lupo.
We are not ending until we pursue him.
Guys, that is our mission.
We don't end until he has been pursued.
I ain't no coward.
He shall remember me in history.
I shall rewrite the romance of the three kingdoms.
Alright, nice.
You know what's crazy?
That TikTok was just gone for like legitimately like one day.
It wasn't even 24 hours!
Wait, no!
I was like, you didn't even make it 24 hours?
That's actually insane.
He didn't even give us the pleasure of fucking grieving for TikTok for 24 hours.
It was just 6 hours.
That's actually crazy.
I was like, oh my god.
And then I see all these depressing tweets from like memes and tweets about how they're like, oh man, I'm so depressed and sad and legitimately like fucking...
I'm gonna download all the best TikToks ever!
And then 6 hours later, JK.
Oh wait, it was 14 hours.
14 hours later, JK.
My death was greatly exaggerated.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Come on, get over here.
You might be 6 feet.
But I'm a short king.
Yay!
Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jokes on you, Doki.
Can't watch the movie.
I'm working on the road.
Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jarhod, thank you for the super chat.
New war cry in Dynasty Warriors Origins for not Doki!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tasty, thank you for the super chat.
Can we watch Blue Beetle next?
Wait, I actually never heard...
I know, like, the character Blue Beetle.
But I feel like I've heard nothing about Blue Beetle.
Like, the movie itself.
It's so bad that no one talks about it.
So it means that it's so bad that it's just mediocre.
That's how bad it must be.
Oh, there's an elder here.
Hello, stranger.
Yes, indeed.
Here, take this with you.
Sword.
Okay.
Oh!
Slash around you?
No, I don't want to use the sword.
You need to hone both mind and body.
Wish to survive the chaos of this era.
One more thing.
I have brothers living here and there.
If you meet any of them, speak with them.
Oh, they can, like, give me stuff.
Ooh, secret.
Gold coin.
We might be here for a while because this is one of the few games that I might do side quest in.
Because Dynasty Warriors is such a favorite of mine.
Like, I just...
I just love Dynasty Warriors so much that I actually really want to do side content.
No, it's because, like, I grew up with Dyna...
Like, it's legitimately one of my favorite games of all time.
Because, like, I grew up with this game and it's, like, my childhood and everything.
That I actually do not mind doing side content for.
Where is the fucking guy?
It's just all the little guys.
Well, I don't care about the little guys.
They don't... Their lives don't matter.
They're just ult charges.
Your lives don't matter.
You're just a number to me.
You don't...
I don't care that I just killed a million fathers.
And all your wives are gonna become widows.
I don't care.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's it.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
That's how little they matter.
Just these.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You wish to pursue Lu Bu.
Didn't know you saw him in a romantic way.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
I'm here to grind those bodies.
Alright, Battle of Wan Castle.
Am I level 4?
I am.
Alright.
The Yellow Turbans in Jin Province have been driven into Wan Castle to defeat...
Jiang Nan?
Oh my god!
I'm gonna defeat hot Chinese Jesus?
Why is he...
Did you know I just found out Sun Jian is supposed to be like...
A similar...
The similar...
A similar age with like one other general.
I forgot who.
Oh wait, no.
It's...
Oh, his younger bro...
Oh, sorry.
His younger brother.
Wrong guy.
His enemy is...
Oh yeah, that's not him.
That's not him.
Yeah, Sun Jian and Qiao Qiao...
Are supposed to be the same age, but then Sun Jian...
Like, he's so...
Why does he look so old?
Okay, sorry.
Jian Jiao is the leader.
Jiang Nan...
It's so weird.
I just...
I don't...
He's always been a crazy wizard.
And now he's like...
Hot.
It's so weird!
I...
Like, I cannot...
Register it.
Alright.
I'm gonna go and kill the big guys.
Because like, I don't trust...
I don't trust Sun Jian to live if I defeat all the little guys.
Like, after...
After almost killing Qiao Qiao...
I feel like if I try to kill the little guys...
I'm just gonna bring them to death.
I'm gonna bring them...
I'm gonna bring them all to die.
Wait, is that one guy?
No way!
There's no way!
Wait, is that him?
Why does he look like that?
Oh my god.
Why are they all...
There's...
There is...
Oh!
No, it's Huang Gai!
Look at him!
It's not so old, Huang Gai.
Oh my god!
I've never seen him young before!
I've never seen him so young!
It's...
Why...
Oh my god, look at him!
Okay, so like, for those who don't know what he looks like...
This is what he's normally...
This is what he normally looks like.
He normally looks like a...
He also usually has a mohawk, but...
From the side profile, I can tell, like...
Cause like, why is he younger than Sun Jian?!
Why did they...
Why did they make him younger than Sun Jian?!
Of all people!
I feel like he'd be...
He should be older than him, right?
I don't know.
I feel like this is how he's supposed to look like.
Like...
You don't wanna...
Bro, he's supposed to be a...
He's supposed to be a gilf, but they made him a dilf.
And he's somehow younger than...
Than the other guy.
Yo, where's our old man?!
Where did he go?!
Alright.
As the head of a military family, I'm not lacking in skill, but anything can happen on the field of battle.
We will need everyone's strength.
Now allow me to explain our plan for the siege.
Our strategy is to break through the castle gates with a baton ram to give our men a path inside.
The base in front of the castle will be critical to our success.
We will take it and then use the supplies to construct the ram.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, there's gonna be a lot of arrows then.
Lord Ju Jian will assault the castle.
We will provide support by engaging the enemy.
Alright.
Okay, we don't care about these guys.
Our favorite horses will be well suited to this sort of mission.
We will take care of it.
Wait, who do I follow?
I swear to God, if they die, I swear to fucking God.
Alright,
I'm ready to begin.
Jarhud, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
New side quest, I'm the Pursuit of Lube Beauty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For the first time, I'm actually gonna...
I'm actually gonna do side quests for the first time in my streaming career.
I've never done side quests before until today.
Oh yeah, do I have to actually pick a kingdom?
Guys, for this...
Do I actually have to pick a kingdom?
Or can I follow all of them?
For this game.
Wait, I do?!
Yeah, but not for a while.
I think I might...
I don't know.
I literally don't know which kingdom I'd pick for...
I don't wanna play as...
It's either gonna be Wu or Xu.
I think.
Because I enjoy...
Xu has some like...
Xu for Zhuge Liang.
Zhuge Liang?
I wouldn't pick Xu just because I love Zhuge Liang.
Because I love his story and I'm obsessed with him.
Wait, what?
Who's shooting me?
Oh my god, it's the...
Fucking, I hate these archers.
But like, that's like...
That's...I don't know.
That's only for that.
Put Tao Tao!
Who's there?
I hate...
I...I think I'll...
I'm definitely gonna...
I'm gonna do...
For sure, I'm gonna fucking come after you.
I don't care.
I'm coming after you.
I don't care about the little guys.
You're all just...
All charges for me.
I...Oh fuck!
Okay, um...
The stupid arrows.
Like...
Oh my god.
You stupid arrows!
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't care.
Those arrows do nothing for me.
You think I care?
That's fucking right.
I don't care.
You might have the arrows.
And I might be like...
Just getting poked by the arrows.
But I don't...
They're like, please!
Use block!
I can't block all the time!
There's too much stuff!
Okay.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Look at that.
See?
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
I don't...
It's fine, guys.
It's fine.
It's so...
It's fine, guys.
It's...
I'm so healthy.
Guys, it's so...
See?
Look at that.
I killed him.
There we go.
It's just that easy.
I might have like...
Those arrows are just acupuncture.
Exactly.
They're just...
It's just...
They're just acupunctures, guys.
It's nothing to me.
Alright.
Let's see.
We defeated one of the big bosses.
So we don't have to worry about these guys now.
They're like, please!
Don't...
Please!
Please block!
Please block the arrows!
For the love of God!
Just block them.
Oh, you thought you have reinforcements?
That's fucking right.
No reinforcements for...
Jesus Christ!
I can barely like...
Attack anybody because of the arrows.
It's actually so annoying though.
I fucking hate the arrow shit.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Okay, please.
They're nothing.
It's just acupuncture.
I'm just getting more relaxed the more they send more arrows at me.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Where's Hwang guy?
Who needs help?
Oh shit.
Don't worry.
I'm coming after.
I'm coming.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry!
Don't worry, sir!
I should really destroy these.
Sorry.
Let me actually give...
Destroy them.
Burn him down!
That's fucking right!
Make sure they're still in there when you burn him down!
Doki, that's arson!
And?
And...
And make sure the entire family is still in the building.
That's right.
Burn it all down.
Press the button.
Alright, let me get rid of this guy too.
Shit.
Oh my god.
I should eat the bread right now.
I should eat...
I'm...
Okay, it is a little concerning that I only have one button left.
It is a little...
Oh shit!
I was supposed to be left side Doki.
I forgot for this game.
I'm supposed to be left side Doki.
Alright.
They can take care of the rest now.
I'll be left side Doki after...
Wait.
Alright.
Where's the...
Where's another archer?
I'm gonna burn it down.
Oh, I know you're here.
No!
Okay.
Our ram needs to be reconstructed.
Real quick.
Let me get rid of...
Let me get rid of this...
Oh shit!
Hong Gai, please!
You're not even...
Oh shit!
Hong Gai, please!
Oh Jesus Christ, you're so young.
Oh my god, you're so young.
Okay, where are the arrows?
I'm ready to burn more things down.
Okay, we gotta kill him.
We gotta kill the...
He doesn't even have a name.
That's how irrelevant you are.
You don't even have...
The history book will not remember you.
That's why no one knows who you are.
Wait, this game has young Hwang?
Yeah, I know.
It's so weird.
It's so weird!
He's so young!
I'm not...
I'm not used to it.
Are they okay over there?
Oh, they're so healthy over there.
I like how like...
We're still waiting for our ram to get there.
And then Liu Bei...
Liu Bei's team is just like...
Feeding the shit out of everybody inside right now.
We're like, give me a sec!
We're almost there!
I'm sorry, I got distracted!
Give me a sec!
I got really distracted, Liu Bei!
Give me a minute!
I'm sure he's fine.
At this point, they're...
Oh, they opened!
Oh, thanks guys!
Thanks!
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
I rolled up the ram and they just opened the door.
They're like, alright, here you go.
What was the point?
We rebuilt that too!
We actually...
Oh shit, I forgot you can't...
We rebuilt that for no reason!
Guys, it's the ef...
Guys, but the effort though.
Guys, but it's the effort though.
Guys...
Wait, is this?
No, that's not actual buns.
We need like actual jars though.
Wait, has summon enemy forces?
Where?
Alright.
Oh, that's fine.
Freedom!
Don't worry.
Oh my god, why is he 8 feet tall?!
Alright, it's over here.
Feel the power of my magic!
Alright, smash this.
Alright, there's more than one.
Where's the next one?
Jesus Christ, you're so tall!
Good ol' evil magic.
Where could the next one be then?
The other side?
Okay, it has to be on the other side then.
I wish I have a horse.
It has to be on the other side.
12 feet tall.
What are they feeding?
Oh my god!
They built a wall!
Holy shit!
How did it get bigger?!
They actually built a wall!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Like, what do I do?!
They actually built a fucking wall!
Oh my god!
Where's the hole?!
Oh my god, the Great Wall of China right there.
It was actually made of people.
Who would've thought?
Oh no, where is it?
Where's the jar?
I can't tell.
It's like... here?
I can't tell!
There's so many people!
Is it here?
Oh my god, there's too many.
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best!
There's a huge wall in front of me!
Okay, I got it.
That should be over.
Nice,
we did it.
That's the sound of freedom if I've ever heard it.
Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'm a little fucked.
I don't have heals at all.
Oh no!
Where are the buns?
I don't know where the buns are!
Where are the mantel?
Please, somebody feed me!
Oh no.
I'm looking for some buns right now.
Are they okay over there?
Chenpoo, are you okay?
Oh hey, the morale has risen.
Okay, is there like fellow bread?
Any fellow bread in Jo- HOLY SHIT!
Okay, he just grew up!
Did you saw that?
He like actually just grew up!
Nice.
That's right, get parried.
Get parried.
Oh shit, where are you?
Wait.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh shit, it's okay.
There's no way I'm gonna get hit.
I'm getting- guys, guys, this is bad.
I'm sort of getting hit right now.
Oh my god, I'm not even getting hit by like- Okay, the worst part is I'm not even getting hit by like him.
I'm getting hit by his little guys.
There we go.
Easy.
Yay!
That's right, I'm gonna kill your brother just like I'm gonna kill you.
Alright, this is where soon-chan's just gonna get a heart attack.
And we never see him again.
Oh my god.
If I see him for more than two more battles, I'd be very surprised.
I- I'm not- no, no.
I'd definitely be very surprised if he lives longer than two more battles.
I- Oh, spoilers.
Please, please don't spoil me a game that has been retoad for like- 20- Not even- For 30- 25 years.
Not even 25.
This game has been retoad for 30 years and- Like- And now we're still here.
And we're still here.
Don't spoil the 1500 year old book.
Wait, no way!
I wanna pause this game right now!
Did you just see who- Did you see who the two people next to them was?
Yeah, they got a little bit cult-y after we left.
Alright, let's move to- Alright guys, it's time.
Oh my gosh.
We're time to kill off right side Doki.
Say goodbye to her forever.
Goodbye.
Goodbye right side Doki.
Now it's left side Doki time.
There was- There can never be two Dokis.
Only one.
Oh my god, okay.
So like, it's so weird seeing them like- It's so weird seeing- Seeing them like this.
Like, the character designs were like- Oh my god, it's just so weird.
That was a long time ago.
That was so long ago, last year.
So long, anything could happen then.
Yeah, and they got real cult-y within a year.
When officials turn to tyranny, it is a sign that imperial power is weakening.
At such times, we must rise to the occasion.
I can- I can't.
Why is he- You're the same age, just- It's very stressful being on the ocean though.
They look so tired.
To be fair, I'm pretty sure Sun Jian's multiple wives and concubines might have like- Made him extra old.
His multiple wives and concubines drained his life force.
He has a lot of kids, guys!
He has a lot of children, okay?
It makes sense when you think about it.
He has a lot of children.
And it sounds legit.
Alright.
Oh my god, do I got any new superchats from ye olde dragoons?
Uh...
Not Doki, I am a- Oh my god, Namus Volunteer, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not Doki, I am the Namus Volunteer soldier who previously sent you a letter.
I want to thank you for saving me again.
Most tend to be intimidated by the ferocity of major battles, but you charge across the battlefield without a hint of doubt.
I am thankful for that, since an enemy officer who was about to strike me down was sent flying by your attack.
Which would be the second time.
Understand that you were formerly a traveling warrior, which begs the question.
Are all warriors these days as strong as- Aw man, thank you ye olde dragoon.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not Doki.
It's me from Puyang.
Man from Puyang, I totally remember you.
Oh my god!
You saved me from attack.
Oh my god, another dragoon!
Guys, we're building up a dragoon fanbase!
2000 years ago!
You swooped in like a bird of prey and smashed through the ranks.
I couldn't believe help would come to a place that even the government forces had abandoned.
All my fellow merchants speak highly of you.
Sorry, I don't mean to speculate or cause you any trouble, but I want to thank you.
I will never forget how you saved my life.
Of course, anything for our fellow dragoon.
Don't worry.
Ancient membership replies.
I saw a superchat that it's somebody's birthday.
Nexy, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Could get a happy birthday from my kami-oshi to make it birth- Of course, Nexy!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Nexy.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Alright, let's create more gems here.
And then...
Is there anything we can add?
Oh, a boost health by 20%?
Fuck yeah.
I feel like health is more important, honestly.
Do I have more?
Is there more...
Special attacks?
No, I think...
This whirlwind kick is...
Oh, it's for like dodging!
Fucking who dodges?
I'm no coward.
I ain't no coward.
We don't need to dodge.
Um, what else?
Change clothing, battle preparation.
Alright, go out.
My 200-year-old superchat.
Oh, shit.
You're Hwang Guy.
Is that you?
Where's your mohawk?
He's just a man now.
Why does he look so plain?
You're just a man.
Not Doki.
He is?
He kinda looks...
He does, he looks so generic.
Like...
His armor doesn't even look...
Show me your arms!
Show me your biceps!
You are a...
You bomb things.
Okay, I don't like that he's not showing his real body.
He always shows his fucking biceps in all the iterations.
He's supposed to be like this guy that just chucks bombs at people.
And I'm like, why are you hiding your most prized possession?
You are a grappler.
Why are you hiding your true weapon?
When you cover it up, you're lowering your stats.
Who covered his arms?
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
It's me from Puyo.
Well, I suppose that doesn't tell you who I am.
But you saved me from attacking yellow turbans.
You swooped in like a bird of prey.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Take it off!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I should be more respectful.
Don't you?
Sorry, I wasn't processing the beginning of what he said.
Because I was mad that he is too cloaked up.
Thank you.
Stop objectifying.
Look at him!
He's built like a fucking tank and he's covering it all up.
What's the point?
What's the point of having a body like that?
What?
Oh, we're gonna win?
Oh my god!
Who would've thought?
I cannot take Lu Bei seriously.
I'm pretty sure they said people are saying that they age them up.
The more you play.
I cannot take K-pop Lu Bei seriously.
I'm sorry.
You're so mediocre Lu Bei.
He's always been mediocre.
She was literally propped up by great generals and warriors.
Led by a mediocre leader.
That's right, I fucking said it.
That's right.
No romanticizing can change my opinion.
Yeah, that's me.
Yeah, I'm doing it!
He's basically a really good politician.
Oh my god, get a horse!
Oh my god, this is my horse!
Let's go!
Okay, I can call upon my left analog stick.
Let's go.
This is my horse.
Isn't he perfect?
Give it a lick.
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
Is there like a store?
Let's help these guys so I can level up.
Reride.
That's Doki Amber Doge, but as a horse.
Can I just do this?
Wait, I can't fight on the horse?
Oh!
Wait, okay, mounted attack.
Oh, they don't have it!
Okay, sorry.
I'm looking at the ride like a win.
Jump, block, mounted attack.
Oh, they don't have...
Okay, for those who don't know.
In Dynasty Warriors.
In the old Dynasty Warriors.
They have a thing.
Where you can just fight on the horse.
So like...
Get over here, horse.
I can't do it.
It would be easier to fight on the horse.
But they don't have it.
Doki...
Yeah, that's the Doki Amber horse.
Yeah!
Yeah, they removed it!
They have charge though.
They removed the horse.
Yeah, the horse strafing.
I missed the horse strafing.
It was so easy.
Yeah.
My da.
Come over here, Doki Amber horse!
Get over here!
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna use the horse attack.
Attacking on the horse seems like...
Really too much.
Hahaha!
I just do that.
Oh!
Don't make me burn your fucking house down!
Oh shit!
I was not paying attention.
Oh my god, please!
There's too many!
That's it.
I'm gonna burn somebody's house down.
Oh my god.
I was facing the wrong direction.
That's alright, I can kill him here.
No?
I don't kill him here?
It's fine, I can kill him here.
Jesus!
Okay, give me a sec.
Where are you?
Hahaha!
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna make sure everybody's widowed after I'm done with all of you.
I don't care.
Hahaha!
None of you will have families.
That's right.
I'm gonna fucking charge in here too.
Oh my god.
The horse is so weak.
Alright, you tell them what I did.
Hahaha!
Bro.
Alright, I'm back.
Now you have no one to help you.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you wanna do that again?
Oh, what you gonna do?
You lost your fucking arrows.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Nothing!
You lost your range attack.
Oh, whoops.
I thought he was dead.
Yeah!
I missed the horse strafing.
I didn't know horse strafing was...
Oh my god.
Like, what's the point of attacking on the horse if you can't strafe on the horse?
Alright, let's get...
Can I... Enables you to evade repeatedly?
Chain evasion?
Is it this?
What's chain evasion though?
Oh, we need more meat buns.
Maybe.
Do you think I can lock on?
I can try that.
Uh...
Where do I have to go?
Oh wait, there's another area here.
I don't know if this is...
If doing the bandit stuff is worth it.
I guess it like, levels you up.
I'll do one more, but I don't know if it's actually worth it or a waste of time.
Oh, I can double dodge?
Okay, wait.
I forgot how to dodge.
Oh, this.
Are you serious?
Okay, this.
That's it.
Alright, it's just an XP farm?
Oh, it does nothing?
Okay, I'll stop doing them.
I don't know if it's like, an actual...
Like, if it's actually good or not.
Doing these.
I guess I don't really...
Oh, fuck.
Ah, get over here!
Alright.
Freedom!
It's kind of a waste?
Yeah, alright.
I'll stop doing the bandit stuff.
I love the ego sound so much.
It's so silly.
It's actually so fucking silly.
I can listen to that fucking forever.
I can listen to that forever.
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ.
Get out of here.
Okay, we gotta get rid of this guy.
Is he the biggest guy out here?
I'm gonna kill the biggest guy out here.
So it's all just short kings.
Only short kings allowed in ancient China.
That's fucking right.
I'm rewriting history.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong attack.
I mean, it still works though.
Nice.
That's right, get parried.
Oh, no.
That's right, I'm doing it for you guys.
I'm doing it for all the short kings in this world!
That's right.
How dare they try to...
What's the word?
Discriminate?
Where like, they only...
They only employ certain groups of people.
And like, they won't employ other groups of people.
Because they're like, you're not tall enough.
Or shit, something like that.
What's that word called?
Discriminate.
HOW DARE YOU DISCRIMINATE AMONGST MY SHORT KINGS!
I'm here to fight for them!
As a fellow short king.
That's fucking right.
How dare you!
Other short kings can be generals too!
That's fucking right.
That's right.
And Chow Chow can be a general at 5'3".
Anything can be possible.
That's fucking right.
For short kings everywhere.
I do it for you.
She's qualified to fight for us.
That's right.
Alright, let's see.
Defeat a hundred foes with...
Oh, I need to use a sword?
But what if I don't?
What if I don't use a sword?
Uh...
Oh wait, what's this?
Xiaohu Yuan?
Did I do it?
Hello, Xiaohu Yuan.
What do you want to talk about?
Hey!
Uh...
What can I do for you?
Yeah, what do you want?
Okay, his voice does not fit his fucking face.
Yeah, why did you come to see me?
I saw something in you.
Which is why I wanted to meet face to face again.
Me?
Uh...
What would that be?
You know what I mean.
After seeing your feats in battle, I have no doubt of your potential.
Lord Cao Cao and Dun liked what you did.
They're not the type to show it.
But they can't fool me.
And if those two take a liking to you...
That means you're the real deal.
That's right.
I'm going to be famous.
And people are going to write about me for generations.
Media not doki.
In that case...
I will be one of the main characters.
Within the story of the three kingdoms.
I will surely be written in history books.
Right, guys?
You're not going to delete me.
Okay, nice.
I'll never be forgotten.
I can feel it.
Oh, there it is.
I'm going to take this gem.
And then...
We should go...
Hello, generic quest giver voice man.
What is my quest now?
Thank you for the super chat.
Wait, what is my mission?
Wait a minute.
I actually don't know.
No, we're not that...
Wait, did I not finish?
Oh wait, I did.
Oh, I have to go back to G.
I have to go back all the way back here?
Where?
Oh my God, I have to go all the way back.
Alright, I just want to make sure...
I got everything done around here.
Okay.
Oh wait, I haven't talked to him before.
Yeah, but I want to travel back...
To see if there's anything I missed.
I want to do all the side quests...
And like...
Go through all the dating routes.
Oh my God.
What's my next route?
What's the next date route?
Oh shit.
Oh my God.
Who's going to be my next option?
It's called...
Romance of the Three Kingdoms, guys.
Yes?
Oh hello, Mr. Dang.
Oh, Mr. Hong.
Sorry, it's first name Hong.
Hello, Mr. Han.
How you doing, Han?
Yes?
Woah.
Of course.
You want to chat?
Oh my God, we're getting the first base already.
Oh my God.
Let me unbutton one button real quick.
You were with the burly men.
You didn't stand out much.
You didn't...
Why is he flirting?
Oh my God.
Okay, do I play hard to get, guys?
Or like...
Do I talk about the burly men that was next to him?
Do I...
I'm like...
Oh yeah, I noticed you amongst those other burly men.
Hahaha.
Oh my God.
He has low self-esteem.
It's perfect.
He's gonna be so easy.
Easy target.
He will have very low expectations, guys.
I can do anything.
I can do anything and he'll think it's like...
He'll think that like...
He'll think it's like the world.
Alright, maybe just order again.
Can you believe my order still hasn't come?
I made it so long ago.
Maybe they forgot it.
Why don't you?
Though I'd wager that you're right.
Why are all my dialogue options makes him feel more shit about himself?
Like, I'm trying to be nice.
No, don't say that, Hong Dong.
Don't say that.
What, being forgetful?
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Bro, your leader literally says you're forgetful and that's a skill?
Not standing out is a skill.
It means you haven't failed.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I actually really wanted to say the second option.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I got plus one in dialogue option.
I got plus one heart.
I did it.
Nice.
I'm so in.
Plus one heart.
It worked, guys.
I did it.
I gave him therapy.
I fixed it.
I told you.
That's it?
That's literally...
It felt like...
It actually felt like a...
It felt like a dating simulator right there.
I just got the Hong Dong route right there.
Are we doing a dating simulator now?
CBMiracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, this is actually a dating...
This is actually like the dating route.
The Hong Dong route.
It kind of is.
Hey, guys.
Romance of the three kingdoms.
Thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As a short king myself, I appreciate you representing us.
Take this as my first ever super chat to a VTuber.
May the short kings conquer the internet.
I shall unite the free kingdoms.
For all short kings out there.
This is a special train...
Oh my god, guys.
He's gonna give me special training, guys.
Oh my god.
Think of me when...
Think of me whenever you use it.
I imagine you won't forget me then.
Not even if you wanted to.
Oh my god.
I imagine that.
Not even if you wanted me to.
Bro.
Oh my god.
It's not even subtle.
Oh, we ain't forgetting that.
Yeah, I am.
Sorry, I was a little distracted with the side routes.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that him?
Wait, he sounds like that?
What?
That's Dong Zhuo.
I thought he has like a pin nose.
It was described!
I'm like speechless right now.
I don't know what to say.
I...
Oh my... What?
I'm speechless.
Oh my god.
I...
I don't know what to say after seeing that.
Oh, I...
I...
I just...
Alright, so...
For those who wanna know...
For those who are like...
What are you seeing, Doki?
He doesn't look that...
Okay, okay.
For those who are like...
I don't understand, Doki.
He doesn't look that hot.
Okay, but like...
You have to know...
Where we came from.
The character designs...
That we all grew up with.
And that's been like...
That's...
That we've had to like...
Look at for...
For nine games.
And like, when you see it...
You'd understand why we're reacting like that.
I...
I legitimately...
I'm speechless.
I...
I was...
I'm not...
I'm not used to this at all.
And then...
And...
Bro!
The glow up!
And then...
Okay, so...
I'll show you a different design of him.
But it's still...
It's basically the same thing.
So like...
You know, like...
It's...
I'm...
And...
Yeah, so like...
I'm not...
I don't know what to say.
I...
How the years...
Changed him.
Like...
He looks like that now.
Like he...
He looks like...
That now.
Like I don't have words.
At what I've just saw.
I don't have words that can...
Describe how I feel right now.
Because it's...
He looks
like a person now.
He looks like a person now.
Oh my god.
It's...
Bro like...
Oh my god.
Bro got some ozone.
What is that?
He changed his life around.
That's for sure.
He actually changed his life around.
Bro's drinking.
Bro went to that fucking gym.
He actually did.
Holy...
My mind is not processing this...
Very well right now.
I'm actually not processing it very well.
I...
Everything is like broke me.
It has all broke me up.
Alright.
Salting the base.
The yellow turbans.
Oh I want the armor.
He actually has legs now.
He can actually walk now.
Oh my god.
Everything like...
Changed for me.
Like...
I think Donja has to be the craziest.
You spoiled his final part.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like...
I just...
I can't process this.
My mind is still stuck on the fact that I just saw...
Handsome Don...
In the books...
He is described as a fucking pig.
Like...
He is actually...
The book was not kind to him.
He was...
Described as like...
Like a pig and like...
One of the ugliest guys in...
In...
In the...
In ancient China.
And very, very fat.
So just seeing him like this.
I'm like...
Who are you?
The slander.
They were just jealous.
You're right.
They were just incredibly jealous of him.
You're so right, guys.
It was all pure slander.
Propaganda.
For the Shu Kingdom.
You're so right, guys.
How dare he.
He has to fight him.
It's just...
It's just incredibly weird.
My head is just thinking...
My head is still thinking about it.
I'm not used to it.
I'm stuck in this loop of...
He's high now.
What happened?
Devs accidentally...
Just make...
If they're all handsome...
Then like...
Then nobody is handsome.
They're all jealous...
Of the big dog.
Oh my god.
I'm still thinking about it.
Guys.
It's so weird.
Because it's been...
20 years of seeing...
Ugly Dong Zhuo.
I'm gonna fucking butcher his name every time.
Because I never...
I hated him as a character.
I hate him as a character.
And I hated...
I just hated everything about him.
So I never see him as relevant.
And now that he's handsome...
It's just...
My mind can't sync up to that.
It's breaking my mind.
It's actually...
It's breaking...
My entire concept of this game now.
And all I can think about is...
Why is he handsome?
Like...
It's breaking my world view.
My entire world view is gone.
Like...
How is that possible?
He's supposed to be like...
He's never was supposed to be attractive.
So why is he attractive?
Han Zhuo broke.
Why is this...
Why is he misunderstood now?
He was supposed to be known as one of the worst people in ancient China.
But now he's just misunderstood?
Oh my god, no.
Now he has character depth?
You mean he's not a cartoon villain?
That was known to commit atrocity?
And then like...
To be fair...
His fucking wife cheated on him with Lu Bu.
So like honestly...
But like...
We've been told for history...
For years that like...
His wife did it because...
He was a very bad husband.
But like...
Oh my god.
But he...
Who wouldn't cheat?
He had a wife.
His wife left him for Lu Bu.
Because...
It's Lu Bu.
Who wouldn't?
To be fair.
Yeah, but then like...
When you know that...
His wife has always...
I forgive him now.
We were all wrong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Guys, I forgive him...
For all the atrocities he's committed.
He was just misunderstood, guys.
I mean, look at him.
He looks like a misunderstood man.
Oh shit, my horse is Walnut.
Oh my god, Walnut!
Okay, I completed the training.
I completed this one.
Okay, can I unlock this yet?
I can.
Alright.
Koi hired all the BLM.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh wait, there's items over there.
Alright.
Freedom!
There's a gem over there too.
Oh no.
Alright.
I feel like I'm playing a dating sim, not gonna lie.
But like...
I feel like I'm playing a...
Oh my god, they knew it.
We always talk about the three kingdoms, but not the romance part of the three.
Finally!
After 25 years!
We finally got the romance of the romance of the three kingdoms.
That's what we've been missing out this entire time.
That's how...
Finally!
After 25 plus years, we finally got what we've all been wanting.
G-Province is the Yellow Turban's headquarters.
In this battle, we'll likely be taking on the main force.
Jaws, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Go show those hippies who's boss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
We'll be fighting a variant, but they may also give us a chance to quell the uprising for good.
I'm told that the government forces will be taking the field under the command of Lord Dong Zhuo.
However, we have not received any particular orders for this battle.
I suppose we would assume that we are free to fight as we please.
Not yet, but we cannot defeat their main force on our own.
We must work with the government forces if we hope to bring down Zhengyao.
That's right.
As far as I can see, both sides of the battle are equal in strength.
Jesus Christ, he's protected by...
Oh my god, I'm scared to fight Zhengyao.
He's actually gonna be so fucking strong.
Um...
He has the power of magic, guys.
Some of the females in this game look dead drunk.
I've only seen one female in this game so far.
Like, I don't...
Not gonna lie, it's a little weird that like...
Um...
Usually in the beginning, they would put like...
You can see some of the female characters in the beginning.
But it is a little weird that...
That...
We've only got one.
We've...
So far, but a lot of handsome men.
It is a little...
Like, where's my Diaochan and Sunshanchan?
And...
To be fair, they all come in later.
But like, in the previous games, they put them in the beginning.
Because they're...
Even though they're supposed to be super young.
But they haven't grown up yet.
So I assume we're gonna see them...
Later on in the game.
Because like...
They have no importance yet.
They have no...
They have no importance until like...
In the next chapter.
Yeah, Sunshanchan is like...
I don't even know if she was born yet.
I think she's like...
She's like 10 or something right now.
If we're going for historical accuracy.
It's sad that...
The bravery and...
Brutality often go hand in hand.
But I admit, I also have a...
Bad feeling about all of this.
Oh, I mean his army looks...
Yeah.
He has Lu Bu, right?
He should have it right now.
Chapter 2 has a lot of time to date women.
But their stream comes with...
Towards both friends and enemies.
In this game, we'll need to react quickly to challenges as they arise.
That will likely be our plan to battle.
We're going to get into a fight without a strategy.
But that is beyond our control.
All we can do now... I'm going to take the building to the right.
Alright.
There's me.
Alright, I'm ready.
Is there anything I should get?
Recruit spear.
Okay, all the other spears are...
Bad.
I need to sell these.
I need to go to the store and sell these real quick.
Walnut!
My little guy!
Yeah!
I'm not ending stream until I kill Lu Bu.
Until I pursue him and kill him.
My little walnut.
Alright, let's go this way.
I want to take the fortress to my right.
They will learn our way of peace and benevolence through violence!
We will lead the attack!
Punch through the enemy formation!
And secure the central stronghold!
We march at once!
Left to fend in red battle areas?
Okay.
That's fine.
It looks like Dong Zhuo's forces are going for a frontal attack.
Wait, where?
Then we will help them by destabilizing the enemy.
Get out of here!
You're too tall!
Short King shall rise up!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
In every iteration of Dynasty Warriors, I have always defeated Lu Bu!
Origins shall not change this for me!
I refuse to let Origins be the first one!
I have always pursued Lu Bu!
And I shall pursue him until the death!
To the dawn of time!
That's right!
I will break you!
Why not marry him instead?
Okay, guys.
There are two different people that play Dynasty Warriors.
Always pursue Lu Bu!
I ain't no coward!
Does Lu Bu have a restraining order against you?
Alright.
We did it.
Get over here!
Doki is both of them.
That's right.
Get over here!
You're too tall!
I refuse to let tall people rule Ancient China!
That's fucking right!
It is time for the Short Kings to rise up and take power!
Okay, nice.
Wait, what?
Who fucking died?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
I'm gonna leave this fight.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
No!
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's a little awkward.
No!
Eat your buns!
Oh, he ate his...
He ate his buns.
It's fine.
He ate his buns, guys.
We're okay.
They all ate their buns.
They did their job.
Oh, my god.
They're so inspired.
This is not fair.
Alright, here we go.
Come on.
Get over here.
Alright.
I live these.
He lives these, too.
You almost died to these weak little guys?
Oh, my god.
The real fight is over there.
Like, excuse me.
I was trying to fight a real general earlier.
And you almost died to...
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I couldn't see.
There was too many people.
There were so many people.
Jesus Christ.
This guy is so annoying, though.
Oh, there's too many little guys around me.
And then there's also arrows.
And where's my arrows?
I don't understand.
Where are my arrows?
I should also have archers.
That's also what I miss in the old...
In the old Dynasty Warriors.
You can recruit, like, archers to fight with you.
Like, little bodyguards and stuff.
And, like, I'm important.
Why don't I have, like, bodyguards?
And then they die.
It's fine.
You can just get another bodyguard.
Okay.
I'm just gonna make sure...
I just need to get rid of...
Okay, guys.
This is a respectful 1v1, guys.
Excuse me.
It's a respectful 1v1.
As all wars should be.
Jesus Christ.
I can't even attack!
Okay, we got it.
Alright, now it's your turn.
Alright, you thought...
You tried a 1v2?
You get punished for that.
Um, no.
I am not a bodyguard.
I am very important in the history of the Three Kingdoms.
If you look through the books, you'll find stories about me.
Wait, how did I... I fucked up my map.
Wait.
Guys!
How do I fix my map, guys?
Oh.
Oh no.
Um, if you open the book and look at a random page for the romance of the Three Kingdoms, you'll see my name.
I'm not... There's no way I get erased from history, guys.
There's no way.
That's crazy.
You mean everything I've ever done is not even gonna like, register?
Like...
Oh, I pressed D-pad.
Alright.
Oh shit, that is so strong.
Okay, I'm gonna kill the reinforcements too.
That's right, walk away.
Alright, nice.
Alright, let me go downstairs.
And I killed the...
What the fuck?
Everybody's just running around.
Okay, we're gonna kill the people downstairs first.
Oh.
How do they have so many fucking forces?
Where's Cao Cao?
Okay, we need reinforcements too.
Wait, he took my castle?
Oh no.
I need to go back.
I'm trying to go back to the main camp, but there's so many people!
Oh no.
Okay.
Alright, there's no way Guan Yu's gonna die.
I refuse to believe that.
I think Guan Yu can take it.
This is not his time to die yet.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
We got another guy.
Stop feeling moral!
Oh my god.
Your eyes can do more than see.
They also enable you such as health and...
Okay.
Who's dying?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Please?
I wanted to take my castle back!
Okay.
That's fine.
We can't let him die.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Freedom is coming in.
Okay, don't worry.
He's gonna eat some bread, guys.
Okay, that's okay.
He's just gonna...
He's just 1v4ing and then he's getting shot at by 200 arrows.
That's okay.
See?
There you go.
I told you.
Everything will be fine.
There you go.
See?
Alright, I just used this on a baby.
But that's okay.
We have two other captains that we can kill.
Alright, you're not dying here today!
You're dying in three more fights, but not today!
It's not written yet!
Don't worry!
I'll kill you later!
This is not your story to die in!
Alright, nice.
Using ults on babies.
Look, I got desperate, okay?
Our guy was whining.
Our guy was fucking wah wah wah.
I was trying to make sure he lives.
Why is he over there?
Okay, please eat bread.
Please eat bread.
Please.
Oh, thank God he ate bread.
Thank God.
I feel like they only eat bread when I show up.
They're like, oh she's here.
I can finally...
I'll finally eat.
Nice.
You almost died to him?
Bread saves all.
Okay.
Alright, then we have to kill this guy.
Okay, there's no way he was gonna lose to him.
Come on.
Come on, Guan Yun.
You're known as like one of the best warriors in China.
We made you into a fucking guy.
You're gonna let this nobody that basically no one has ever talked to except for the Dynasty Warrior games?
You're really gonna let him.
Like, look at him.
Look at him.
Look at his head.
His head's so stupid.
Oh, Guan Yun was winning.
Doki, you interrupted his fight.
He was not winning shit.
He literally got like 30 damage in and then that was all he did.
It's a good hat.
You're just jealous of his hat.
It's a good hat, Doki.
Oh, look at that.
Guan Yun didn't even come back to help me on this fight.
I came back to help him and he's like, you got this.
Nice.
Oh shit, I got his weapons too.
Now I have the fist.
Oh my god, I'm Iron Fist.
Wait, I'm Iron Fist.
Wait.
You can never escape.
Wait, how do I...
JR, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Hope you're doing well.
It's somehow snowing where I am, which is northern Florida.
I love global warming.
Guys, I don't...
I'm a little worried.
Oh no.
You never escape.
But thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's just get rid of these guys really fast.
Let's get rid of the guy that has a name.
Obviously the no name guy is not that important.
Alright, you're too tall.
Wait, I can crypter in battle?
Wait, I can.
Alright, it's time.
I know this weapon might be... Wait, it's stronger.
Wait, is it stronger?
Oh my god, it is.
It's time.
That's right.
I'm Iron Fisting now.
That's right, I'm parrying.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's like different...
There's actually different combos.
Wait, they have different combos and everything.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the castle back.
I'm pretty sure they'll be fine.
Yeah, I have different stances that I can use.
No way she can parry now.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, get over here.
I'm taking back my castle.
Okay, Guanyin, you should be fine.
Oh my god, wait, that's so cool.
Oh my god, I can like swap and everything too.
Oh!
Now it's like, give me back my castle.
Give it back to me!
Give it back!
That's fucking right!
I shall beat you all up!
This is my castle now.
That's right!
You are all free!
I love that scene.
You are all free now.
This kung fu hustle.
I'm beating these enemies off.
This is mine.
You got it back.
The classic.
That scene is amazing.
Alright, back to Okay, now we should be able to kill Zhengjiao, right?
Right, guys?
Alright.
There's no way he's gonna like trick us all this time, right?
There's gonna be no stupid magic tricks this time.
Alright, guys.
Are you guys ready?
I'm ready.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
Don't worry, they're civilians.
That makes...
That's not better, but like don't worry, they're not trained like us.
A massive gathering can sometimes form a large force.
Officers will have high courage and will act posing a grave threat.
To bring that, you must defeat its officer, reducing its fighting strength and causing it to die.
After a large collapse, troops will...
That's easy.
That's basically what I've been doing this entire time.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That's
it!
To war!
For Doki!
Holy shit!
That's actually so cool.
I love that.
To for Doki!
Oh shit.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
Oh.
Jesus Christ, there's so many people.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna keep punching you.
That's right!
Get kicked!
Oh!
What?!
That was such a parry!
That should have counted.
That should have fucking counted.
That's fucking right.
I think you're gonna get away with this.
You might have...
You might have arrows.
Oh fuck, okay.
I'm getting lost in the sauce though.
I'm actually...
I'm getting a little lost.
There's way too many things.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I'm gonna get to you though.
There we go.
I got one of the... I got one of the large forces.
That's all that matters.
I said parry this, exactly.
Alright.
We gotta get rid of this leader.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, full infantry charge?
Oh no!
Oh, they're calling it!
The enemy is attempting to stop them by meeting certain conditions.
Okay, we got it.
Okay, we have to kill 200.
Oh no, gotta get rid of the majority of the army.
Don't worry.
Okay, I will, but like after this, I have two minutes?!
Oh, this is bad.
It's so bad because I'm trying to kill a general too.
That's fine.
38.
Army of one, that's right.
That's right.
Okay, now I'm ready to actually kill 200.
I'm ready to kill 200.
That's fucking right.
60, 89.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm fucking, I'm heading there as fast as I can.
That's alright.
121.
I can make it, I can make it, I can make it.
I believe.
Oh, I believe.
Oh, there's so many people!
160, 70.
30 more.
Oh, I'm getting beat up everywhere!
There's so many people!
Everybody's fucking...
They're all, like, throwing me around!
Oh, one more, one more, one more!
Holy fuck!
I feel like I was just flip-flopping everywhere.
There were so many people, like, where do I go?
There were so many people on me.
That was actually crazy.
That was close!
That was so close, that was so close.
I need to find, like, bread.
I ran out of bread though.
That's pretty bad.
There we go.
Can't get him though.
Please, one of them has to be able to...
I'm, like, a little worried because, like, I really, really need bread.
Please, somebody drop some.
Thank you.
Oh, thank god.
One last boss right here.
Grapple, get grappled, get grappled!
That's fucking right!
That's here!
I'm gonna use it!
Push him!
Oh my god, that did nothing though.
That actually did nothing.
Who's gonna lose?
Oh, it's Chen Yao right there.
Oh, I'm a little worried right now.
I am maybe a little worried because...
oh!
Oh, I don't have bread!
I'm... I'm scared.
I am 1 HP, guys!
I am 1 HP and I don't have bread, guys!
I... I have zero bread, guys!
Oh, what do I do?
Oh!
Oh, no!
Lu Bei, what?!
Lu Bei, eat bread right now!
Lu Bei, eat some bread!
Please, please, eat some bread for the love of god!
For the love of god!
Lu Bei, please!
Lu Bei!
Please!
For the love of god, just eat anything!
I just don't die!
Lu Bei!
Okay.
That's fine.
As long as...
As long as we just beat him up.
Oh, oh, nice!
Parry!
There we go!
We're doing it!
This is fine!
I just keep... There we go!
I didn't parry it successfully.
But... Oh, nice!
His defense is down!
Keep beating him up!
We did it!
Oh my god, Lu Bei!
Is he alive?
Oh, he's alive, thank god!
This versus Doctor Strange is a canon event.
Wait, we haven't won...
What the fuck?!
What?!
He just fucking stabs me!
It's like, it's not over yet!
Stab!
The random guy that just...
The one guy that just stabbed me!
We did it!
Oh, thank god Lu Bei survived.
I got a little scared there.
That little goblin.
But um...
He stabbed me and I was like, I thought the game was over.
And I was used the Serpent Stance by pressing L, B, Y.
Oh shit, another attack.
And I was used the Phoenix Stance by pressing L, Y while evading.
L, Y while evading.
L, Y...
Okay.
Unlocked a new skill.
Wait, isn't that like a new panel for my...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yay, Walnut!
You're doing it, my little guy!
I didn't hear no bell.
Oh, I did!
Okay.
Uh...
What is this?
Increase health?
Okay, boost attack strength by boost defense.
Okay.
Grants bravery when evading justice.
Does it use both of these?
Or like only one of them?
Guys.
Like, it uses both of these, right?
At the same time?
I just wanna be sure.
Both?
Okay.
Taking...
Okay, wait.
What's this?
What the fuck?
I don't even think I could do something like that.
That's...
That looks way too cool for something I can do.
That looks way too fucking cool.
I did it.
And it seems you've proven that you can at least survive.
What?
Lupe was definitely hanged by the thread there.
He was...
He was not doing okay.
Now, let me ask you.
Out of curiosity, what do you think of the super chat?
What do you think of the super chat?
God, I love Hack and Slash in rock and roll.
I love Hack and Slash.
I love like Ted Why is he empty?
Why has he been forsaken by the heavens?
Fallen from grace?
Righteousness, power.
I think righteousness...
Oh no!
They made him more...
They made him more of like an enemy that you can like sort of like be like he's just misunderstood.
I'll just say power.
He's weak.
He's a fucking hippie.
That's right!
You know what?
Maybe he was right.
Maybe don't...
You know, I think now that I see him in a new light and he's like a little more attractive now and not an ugly pig.
I think I understand him now.
I think he was just misunderstood.
Not shallow.
Superficial doki.
Maybe it wasn't so bad.
Oh my god!
How do you keep showing up?
Are you like...
Are you part of my mind?
Don't worry.
I still have the power of freedom.
That's like a real thing though.
Apparently like it's really fucked up but like it's actually real.
Where like um...
People are more willing to agree with you if you're attractive.
It's fucked up but it's actually true.
Oh there's that...
Oh wait, that's the one I equip.
Uh... Do I need range or...
Boost damage dealt to enemies?
I feel like maybe the damage because I'm parrying a lot.
To be fair.
I'm doing a lot of parries.
Do I have whirlwind kick?
I don't.
I think I don't.
Elbow strike, palm strike, whirlwind...
Yeah, I don't have whirlwind kick.
Divine bird's wing.
Nah.
Wait, is that why people always agree with you?
Uh...
What's this?
Wait, is it feeding time?
Okay, I'm...
After this cutscene, I need to feed Doki Amber Doge, not Doki Amber Horse.
You figured it out.
If you followed the flow of incense here, that means you are a guardian of peace.
Oh, am I in the Zhenjiao route now?
Am I...
Am I really doing peace by killing people?
I thought... I said that as a joke.
I...
I shall spread peace with one...
With one slice at a time!
I don't.
Peace through power and war.
A guardian of peace.
One who knows not their duty judges me.
If that is not the will of the heavens, then I am at a loss.
Heaven and earth try to judge me.
I will not stop believing in my righteousness as long as others ask it of me.
I know that this path, this ideal, is not a mistake.
And why is the heavens trying to stop you?
You will lose nonetheless.
And while your men run amok, you truly think so?
Now I'm gonna say he's gonna lose.
Nah, I win.
I am right.
And therefore, I will not lose.
I cannot.
Our fates are intertwined.
I shall await the day I see you in battle.
This is such like...
What's the word?
That entire sentence contradicts each other.
I am Zhang Zhao.
The general of heaven.
These two hands will upend the heavens if need be.
Oh, that poor guy.
He thinks he's a god.
I shall...
I shall see you in battle, guard you in a piece.
Alright.
Let's talk to Dong Zhuo.
Hello.
Oh my god, is this his route?
Oh, he thinks it's hot.
Oh my god, the Dong route.
Not the Dong route.
Oh!
Guys, he's a lord.
Oh, um...
Oh my god.
Okay, before I...
Before I do the Dong route, let me...
Let me feed my dog.
For you, dog.
Alright.
Badoki, what about Hong Dang?
Who?
Who are you talking about?
Hong who?
For you, Dong Zhuo.
Oh my god, you're so right, Lord Dong Zhuo.
So true, bestie.
According to Wikipedia, Dong tortured people in Banquets.
That's fake!
Anybody can write a Wikipedia article!
Look at him!
He would do no such wrong.
I bet you they... I bet you his aunties rewrote the wiki.
It's propaganda by his enemies.
I didn't...
I just said one thing.
I literally...
I literally listened to him like talk about himself and then he's like, alright, I'm done now.
You can go.
He's like, I'm fucking done talking to you.
I'm like, okay.
Oh, let me give you a farewell admission.
He likes it.
He likes to hear himself talk.
Defeat 100 enemies, cause a foe's large fort first, conquer base three times.
Alright, no problem.
Alright, Lu Bei.
It would be best to focus before we head into battle.
I for one can't help but get excited.
What's wrong, brother?
No.
It's just that it feels like I'm dreaming at all.
We started out merely wanting to help those who are suffering.
And now we are fighting alongside the land's finest warriors.
Think about that.
We are about to make an incredible difference in this realm.
Yes, you, me, you, Guan Yun, Zhang Fei, and I.
The fourth sworn brother.
I am sure that sort of talk can wait until the victory... They'll always remember there was always four.
Lord Sun Jian.
Never three.
Never five, but four.
The tales of your volunteer army's exploits have made the rounds.
Quite impressive.
Hmm.
Feels strange hearing that from you.
Friends with the Tiger of Jiangdong as well, I see.
Truly an army to be reckoned with.
The original short king.
But those who don't know, he was apparently five foot three.
Yes.
He is a role model to us all.
It all depends on the upcoming battle.
It will soon be time for us to depart.
Be sure to make your preparations by then.
My hero!
He is truly our hero.
Alright, let's get this.
Uh, recommend level six.
Oh, I'm level eight.
Avelion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, the fourth sworn brother had to return to your home planet at the end of the Yellow... No, no, no.
I'm gonna be here for... I'm gonna be here for a while, right guys?
They'll remember me for thousands of years.
It's always been the four musketeers.
Not three, but four.
Defeat all the...
Wait, defeat how many?
Defeat all the bandit officers.
So...
One, two... Okay, over there.
Just like the four musketeers, guys.
That's me.
Alright, let's get rid of him.
Oh, he also is using his fist.
But I have bigger fists.
That's fucking right.
My fists are stronger.
Yeah?
Goodbye.
Oh, I should get the base back too.
Alright, let's get rid of...
Capturing the base increases the more the situation becomes more favorable.
Oh, okay.
So it's better to keep capturing bases.
Alright, let's see.
And then we go...
Where's the other bandit officer?
Jesus Christ, there's two.
One here.
Okay, I'll go...
Go downstairs then.
Actually, no.
Left side might be easier.
Wait, why are they all so fucking far away?
Oh my god, they're all so far.
I'm just gonna do the left side first.
Unless you have to babysit your...
Oh, really?
Oh, I just gotta make them happy.
They'll be fine.
Fuck it.
There's no way the general down there is gonna die.
Let me check real quick.
Yeah, they got this.
I believe in them.
The power of friendship.
Alright, let's kill the big generals here first.
The harder generals.
Oh.
Oh, they'll be fine.
I believe in them to survive for like a couple seconds longer.
Let's just kill these guys first.
Alright.
Come on.
Get over here.
I got my...
You think a sword is gonna beat these fists?
I played Marble Rivals.
I never played Iron Fist, but I played Marble Rivals.
And I think I know how it works by watching people.
It's almost the same.
I like how I'm like getting poked by like acupuncture arrows in the side, but it literally means nothing to me.
Alright, nice.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
My randoms are doing it.
Look, he's not even fighting back!
You have a sword, but he's not even fighting back.
Alright.
Nice.
Let me get rid of him.
Alright.
Bandit chief, bandit chief, bandit deputy.
Wait, it's just the bandit officers.
Okay, so...
Oh, that'll be fine.
We have a sure victory now.
The advisor?
Who the fuck sent in the advisor to fight?
What the fuck?
That guy's a nerd!
That poor nerd!
I'm beating...
I'm gonna stuff him in the locker!
That's right.
Poor guy.
He got stuffed in the locker.
That poor guy.
I don't know why...
I don't know who brought you in here.
I was not the one that brought him to the battlefield.
I don't know... Oh my god, another one.
I'm gonna kick this nerd's ass.
You're in the wrong war, nerd!
Get back in your tent!
I don't know why you're here!
Get back in that tent, boy!
Let's get the assault right here first.
He's trying his best!
He made a mistake!
That's right!
You see that, nerd?
That's gonna happen to you!
That's right!
Get over here.
All my might!
Not even gonna...
I'm not even gonna go easy.
Alright.
Get him out too.
Jesus Christ.
I need to make sure.
Come on.
Oh, that's not who I'm trying to fight!
No!
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
He's almost dead anyway.
Oh my god.
This is actually so annoying.
This like 1v2 is so fucking annoying.
I hate it.
Your feats paved the way for allied supremacy, even without raising morale is enough.
Oh, okay.
It's automatic victory now.
You see that?
You're next.
Exactly.
You see that?
You see what happened to you?
You're fucking next!
That's right, nerd!
I'm gonna pull your underwear up your head!
Take this!
You might as well be a nerd to me.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Where are the other bandit chiefs?
Bandit deputy, bandit...
I'll ride up.
Alright, we go up now.
We have to save...
Well, apparently it's like...
We already win, but I still have to kill everybody.
Let's dash faster.
Come on, Walnut!
Giddy up!
Giddy up, my little guy!
Come on, you got this!
Which one?
This one?
Oh shit, you are.
Don't worry, I'm here now.
See?
Good for you.
I don't know how you almost died there, but good for you.
Alright.
Let's grab this base back.
Oh wait, another general showed up.
Oh my god, the nerd went to the fight too?
Who keeps putting all these nerds into this fight?
Okay, parry.
Oh, fuck this.
I know they're nobodies, but who cares?
The enemy officer has been defeated.
There's not enough lockers to stuff all these nerds in.
Who let this one...
Okay.
Alright, we should own this now.
Whoops, I did not mean to eat a bun.
Alright.
There's two more deputies.
Okay, this fucking accessory better be worth it because this is a long ass...
This is a long ass side mission.
I swear to god, if this is a dog shit accessory that I'm not even gonna equip, I will be very sad.
Oh my god, there's so many.
There's too many big people that I have to get rid of.
Okay, nice.
I have extra damage.
The enemy courage has...
Did we win automatically?
At this point?
They don't even have courage.
Oh, they don't even fight back anymore!
Guess they lacked all courage.
Nice.
And then...
Gotta go downstairs for the last fight.
Yeah, they lost all their HP.
I don't think I like this mission.
This one definitely feels like it drags on for way too long for how easy it is to beat.
I basically beat this mission within the first two fights, but I still have to finish it.
This seems like an incredibly long side mission.
Let's dash up here.
Yeah, the map is too big.
It should've definitely been shorter.
Alright, now eat your bun.
I'm here now.
Eat your bun!
Nate, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay, that should be everybody.
Yay!
Is this a tutorial?
I guess it teaches you the tutorial about the morale and courage, but I feel like a little too late.
I don't know.
It feels like a little too late to teach me about...
teach me that.
Means press 31.
I wanna level up all of this first.
What can my horse do now?
Spur on...
Encourage replenishing some...
Okay.
This is why you don't send your advisors to battle.
Gauntlet of Dispersion.
What is that?
Is this gonna stop?
I feel like I parry.
Successfully stop an enemy attack with special arts.
I do that a lot too, but I don't know.
I think I'll wait.
I'm gonna wait until I unlock a second one first before I do that.
No, I don't think it is a parry buff.
I think it's like...
I mean, it's not really parry.
It's your special arts.
It's my special ability.
Alright, this one.
The yellow...
Final battle against the yellow turbans.
Alright, here we go.
We're finally gonna kill the hippie.
The cult leader.
Alright...
I just...
Please tell me he grows a mustache.
Please...
Tell me Chao Chao grows a...
That's all I want.
I just want him to have a mustache.
It's so weird.
It's so...
It's so weird seeing him...
It's like he's bald, but like worse.
It's...
Okay,
they can't die.
Yeah.
Alright,
so...
I'm gonna take the castle first.
And then, after that...
Uh...
I'm gonna simply wait for the right moment to finish the fight.
You do understand.
The volunteer army will be... You should read the situation and take what you believe to be best course.
Yeah, I'm gonna follow the mobile army.
History says bye to DLC.
They lock the mustache in the DLC pack.
Imagine if they actually do that.
That would be so fucked if they locked that.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
It's just weird.
If he feels naked without his mustache...
It feels like he's just...
He's a cosplayer, but like...
Did like 80-70% of the effort of cosplaying him.
He's the same age as Sun Jian!
I don't understand!
Sun Jian!
He just has... I guess...
I guess his life force just got drained.
Like, I feel like I'm starting a K-pop group.
It's like...
The American dad...
Boy band...
Some of it again.
B-12.
I think...
I feel like this is B-12 right now.
I'm B-12.
I feel like this is...
I'm just starting my...
The ancient China B-12 group.
Wait, how do I get to the top?
Wow.
Wait, how do I get up there?
Wait,
how do I get up there?
I thought I was gonna get up there.
I'm not.
I thought I could get up there!
I don't know how!
Oh, okay.
I do now.
Guys, I found the ladder.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, not really.
I am...
I am a little lost.
How the fuck?
Oh, he's dispatching soldiers.
I hope people don't die while I'm being lost.
I...
I am...
Oh, no.
I am a little lost.
I'm sorry, team.
Okay.
Oh, I almost got off the bridge.
I'm okay.
Oh, no.
It'll be fine.
I'm here to help!
That's right!
I know you... Oh, wait.
They were doing okay.
They didn't need me.
But I'm still here to help!
I know you guys didn't need me, but don't worry.
The hero is here.
Okay, maybe I went the wrong way.
No, no.
I know what I'm doing.
Okay, I go here.
Oh, I should have been following the reserve.
Whoops.
That's okay.
Don't worry.
I'm getting... I got the back.
I got the back shots.
Don't worry.
We're so ready.
They don't know I'm here.
That's right!
They never expect a back.
Wait, what?
Oh, I got them!
Oh, it's the ambush buff.
That's fucking right.
I got the ambush buff right here.
Oh, they're scared now.
They're so scared!
None of them ever expects the...
No one ever expects the back.
Nice.
Oh, that's right!
All of China is here to get rid of you hippies!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Alright, let's go.
They're gonna go up here.
No one expects the shots from the back.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, Guan Yu, I got you!
Don't worry!
Your hat's fucking ugly!
That's right!
I'm gonna kill you with your own hands!
You see these fists?
Those were your arms!
That's fucking right!
I got your hands!
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
I got the parry!
That's fucking right!
You have no more armor!
Stop hitting yourself!
I missed the parry.
God damn it.
I fucked it up.
Oh, he fucking recharged it too!
That should be illegal.
You shouldn't be allowed to recharge your hands like that.
Okay, parry.
Don't worry, I got more.
That's right!
Goodbye!
Now I have two of your hands!
That's goddamn right!
Now I steal all your hands!
Alright, we go this way.
Ancient Chinese Wolverine.
No, it's literally Iron Fist.
I beat him with his old hands and then took his new hands.
And then I'm gonna take his wife too.
I'm sorry.
Find out where your wife is!
Oh my god!
So cute!
And the kids too.
That's right.
Please!
You already took everything he loves!
How much more do you want?
I want everything.
I wanna make sure he knows he lost everything from me.
Alright, let's get rid of this old man.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
You're too old to be fighting still.
Get out!
That's right!
Talk to this hand.
Alright, let's see.
Where do I go now?
Do I help him?
Oh my god, there's He-Man again.
It's him again.
I'm trying to figure out where to go to help.
Oh no, we're thinking about...
It's like foreshadowing Dong Zhuo now.
Go away, freedom!
Ah!
Okay, you gotta sound less pathetic, buddy.
You really...
You really need to sound a little less pathetic, buddy.
I'm a little...
Oh man, no wonder you're... You know, I sort of understand why you're...
Someone noticed me!
Oh my god!
Bro, buddy!
Buddy, please!
Be a little less pathetic, buddy!
History will remember Hong Dang!
Guys, don't worry!
History's gonna remember him!
Alright, where's the last guy?
Alright, the last guy.
Or second last guy.
Alright, we got him out too.
And then...
Last last last guy, for real.
No, I can't be bothered.
You're just gonna get a full Musou attack.
It only does 185?!
Like, what's the point?!
Oh no.
Oh no, they're gonna use magic again.
Oh no, give me a sec.
Wait, why won't it let me...
Hello?
Oh, okay, I was gonna say.
God damn it!
Wait, what?
Launch a fierce attack with phantom soldiers?
Find and defeat Chen Jiang?
Where?
Up there?
Wait, what?
Wait, I'm not there yet!
Oh no!
Give me a sec!
I'm not even there!
Oh, I found him.
Oh, okay.
I did it.
Nevermind.
He's right here.
He's...
Okay, alright.
That's fine.
That was just that easy.
He was just right there, guys.
He was actually...
Oh, you were just there.
Thank God.
Alright, thank God.
I don't have to do much.
It just works.
He was literally just in front of me.
Okay.
So we just gotta defeat him.
I like how the phantom soldiers is just like, Yeah, you go there, boss!
You got this, boss!
And then he's just...
You don't need our help!
You go!
Go do your thing, boss!
It all works out.
Wait, what might...
Which one?
You got this!
I know we were supposed to be your bodyguard, but like, I believe in you.
Catch those hands!
Nice.
Real support.
We did it.
Oh shit, where?
Wait, they're all dead.
No, you're fine.
Oh my God, finally.
He's dead.
Our commanders are...
They were struggling against nearly ghosts.
Nice.
I did it.
Oh shit, you gotta eat some bread, Tao Tao.
It's time.
Are you guys ready?
For Doki!
Let's go!
And then we get off the horse.
Charge!
That's fucking right.
Oh, I should have used that.
Oh my God, there he goes.
There he goes.
How?
Who is inspiring you?
I killed his brother!
Okay.
Alright, we gotta kill them right here.
Nice, we blocked.
My...
That's fucking right.
I got the Y.
It's Y assault time.
Get that.
Get over here.
Jesus Christ.
They're all so tanky.
Oh my God.
What?
Bale of mist.
Oh no.
Bale of mist vanished.
Destroy the scent.
Are you serious?
They're all gone?
Where?
I'm so confused.
Where are they?
What?
Where is it?
Oh, there's over there.
It's over there.
I was like, where is it?
How do I get up there?
Oh no, I'm trying to figure out how to get up though.
Oh, not four minutes.
It's like up top, but like, how do I get up top?
Oh no, the magic from the...
God, stop being dumb!
These stupid ones!
How do I get up top?
Okay.
Oh no.
I'm trying to figure out how to get up top.
I'm so confused.
No, the horse can't jump!
Oh my God.
Where is the high ground?
I'm trying to figure out how.
Oh, he can?
How do I get up?
How do I jump up, guys?
Here?
No, I can't!
Oh, I can, I can, I can!
Okay, I figured it out.
No, no, no, no!
I'm heading over!
I'm heading over, Cao Cao!
I'm heading over, please!
I'm fucking...
I'm running over!
Please!
Cao Cao, please!
I figured out how to jump, Cao Cao!
Please!
I'm trying my best!
Okay, we did it.
That's right, I know magic too.
Burn it!
Oh, I do not have enough allies.
Whoops, sorry.
Okay, I need a fight.
Oh my god!
Guan Yun, are you okay?
Where are the leaders?
Where are they?
Your allies are preparing a grand tactic.
Preparations, when your allies are ready, approach them with a tactic.
They'll bring a heavy blow.
Oh my god, I'm ready.
I'm fucking...
No, Cao Cao!
Oh my god!
I just got here!
What do you mean?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I literally...
I just got here!
I...
I immediately failed.
I don't...
I don't understand!
Oh my god!
I literally just got here!
How did you fucking die?
Oh my god!
Why didn't you eat bread?
That's all you had to do!
You just had to eat bread!
I don't understand why they can't just eat bread.
Oh my god!
Please!
I am fighting my fucking heart out for all of you guys.
Like, I don't know what you want from me.
I'm literally fighting my...
I'm like your strongest character right now and I'm fucking trying my best.
Look, it's not... I'm just saying like...
Please!
Like...
I'm literally like doing my absolute best right now.
There we go.
I went straight for the general at this point.
Oh my god!
How did only Cao Cao die?
How?
Don Juan lived longer than you!
I have to eat the bread.
Oh shit, not the reinforcements.
Oh my god.
Oh dang!
I survived Cao Cao.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh no.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, this is gonna be a 1v1.
Oh my god, the voices, they're calling me.
They're calling me.
What do the voices say?
Hello?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe Cao Cao died.
I can't believe he just fucking... I just got there and it was like, he's dead.
I'm like, oh, okay.
Okay.
I didn't expect him to just die like that.
But okay.
Okay.
Alright, let's get the attack.
History changed so much for the short game.
Look, he's trying his best, okay?
He's trying so hard, okay?
It's not my fault that like...
that like, he tripped and fell.
Alright, guys?
What's this?
Is this gonna be a 1v1?
Hello?
He just hasn't got his mustache yet.
What the fuck?
Magic is real?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I thought it was all tricks.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I got scared.
I was not expecting real magic.
I thought...
Oh my god, I didn't realize magic was real!
Holy shit!
It was real this entire time?!
He's a witch!
I killed him!
Oh my god.
He was actually a witch.
How do I fucking get rid of the rocks?
Do I just block it or evade it?
Oh shit.
Guys, please.
I haven't learned how to... I haven't learned how to guard the rock yet.
I'm burning a witch right now.
He's actually a witch!
Do I just... Can I block it?
Oh, I can.
Look at that.
Oh my god, look at those poses though.
Okay, that...
The pose is funny.
Okay, I can actually block it.
Alright, watch.
Oh, that's slay, girl.
Oh shit!
That's not fair.
I wasn't ready.
Come on.
Get out of here.
Oh shit!
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?!
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Well, let me just slay.
Slay.
Okay.
Slap that magic out of him.
That's fucking right.
How dare you use magic?
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ.
Nice, I got it before he could use it.
Take this!
Jesus Christ, he's so fucking tanky!
He's actually...
I got it before him.
He's so tanky.
It's actually crazy how tanky he is.
Come on.
I got the Y.
I don't think I can win this.
I have...
What?
Can I block this?
Oh, I can't!
I have to actually avoid it.
Oh, I'm a little worried.
I've only got to half HP.
I'm a little worried, guys.
I'm...
Oh, I'm a little worried.
I don't know if I can survive.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Guys, this is my last bud!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I have one more button left, but...
Oh!
Oh, there's too many rocks!
Oh, fuck!
I couldn't evade it, guys!
I got confused!
Oh my god!
Okay, this boss fight is difficult.
This boss fight is very scary.
I'm not doing as much damage as I would like.
Oh no!
Oh!
My heart is beating!
Guys, it ain't looking so good!
It ain't looking so good!
It's not looking so good, guys!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god!
I'm getting a focus up!
Oh no!
Okay.
Dash!
No!
Oh my god!
I pressed R2!
Recreate battlefield?
Wait, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
There's bread, but oh my god!
See?
There's 2, 4, 6, 8 bread!
Oh, it rewinds time?
After being defeated, this lets you take yet another look at how an event... Oh!
Oh, I know exactly what I did.
That was not good.
I know exactly where...
I ain't no pussy!
Wait.
Do I fight him here?
Or...
I ain't no pussy!
Oh, I can go back to before he died?
Oh wait, is this before he died?
Or like here?
Is this before he died or is this where I start the battle?
I don't remember.
Cause like, what's the difference between these two?
Oh!
Okay, let's just restart from the beginning cause I want to keep my bread.
Can I bring my horse?
Wait, I can bring my horse.
A giant rock is fucking annoying.
My damage is way too low.
Yeah, I'm skipping this.
Jesus, guys, I'm a little worried about the Lu Bu fight now.
Guys, I don't know if I should pursue...
Guys...
Do I actually pursue Lu Bu?
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
If Chang Qiao is like this difficult...
Oh my god.
Wait, how difficult is Lu Bu?
No.
Oh my god.
Do we pursue Lu Bu?
Okay, nice.
Don't worry, I got this.
Oh my god, they like actually Dark Souls this too.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
I figured out the little rocks but the big rocks is where I'm a little scared though.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I got it.
Nice, I got the parry.
Come on.
Got the parry in though.
Nice.
Block, block, block.
Oh shit, I miscounted.
I actually miscounted that.
I didn't mean to do that.
I was like, that's right, I got you.
I was like, I didn't see the last rock at all.
No, nice.
No, I didn't get it?
What?!
Did she just say my apology after fucking me up?
I can't believe I didn't get that.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna eat the button real fast.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh, this is the halfway point.
Okay, that's fine.
Take this.
Attack, Taz.
That's fucking right.
That's right, I can block this.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god.
Are you serious?!
Oh my god, I couldn't interrupt it in time.
I was gonna interrupt it.
Nice, okay, I got the interruption.
Come on, take it.
Oh, nice, parry.
Get parried.
Parried, you fucking wizard!
Oh!
Haha, that's right.
I just run away.
Are you serious?!
Oh my god!
Oh, I hate that move, I hate that move.
I have to be, like, close to him to do it, so it's so frustrating.
Take this.
Because I'm not close enough.
I got it, I got it in time.
Is that it?
Nice.
What?
Oh my god, I didn't get my assault, there we go.
My arm is too short!
It's fucking right.
I know I can block that, it's not right!
What?
Nice, parry.
It's fucking right, got your shield.
It's not...
My hands might not do that much damage!
But that's okay, I'm right next to you!
What?
Okay, act like a party.
I love that.
All I can think about when I see him block, that's literally all I can think about.
Oh no, oh no.
What?
Yeah?
Child?
God of War?
Oh my god, am I gonna go rage mode?
Oh my god!
It's time!
It's time, we're back!
We never left God of War!
It's fucking time!
You fucking...
Oh my god!
Oh my...
We never left!
I'm getting over!
I'm heading over!
It's rage art time!
That's right, we never left!
It's anger time!
Wait, that's it?
Wait, wait, that's not fair!
Wait, wait a minute!
Wait, there's one of me!
There's one of me!
Wait, that seems a little unbalanced now.
Wait a minute, where's my allies?
Wait a minute!
Wait, you get tornadoes too?
Oh my god!
Alright, if you're gonna...
Okay, let me get the buttons real quick.
Let me...
Let me grab these, then.
If we're gonna be doing this.
Alright, I don't know...
Oh, thank god, okay.
You are...
This looks...
Alright, guys.
It's Kingdom Hearts now.
We're gonna Kingdom Hearts this.
Oh my god, what kind of magic is he bringing forth now?
Okay, defeat 300 enemies.
Okay.
Alright, we got 59 right now.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, 100 and we got 100 already.
Alright.
It's time!
It's actually Kingdom Hearts time!
We gotta get rid of all the Heartless!
Jesus Christ.
200.
I'm so close to the next one.
Oh!
I don't care.
We're trying to get rid of the small... Holy fuck!
What the fuck out of my ear!
Help!
What the fuck!
I didn't travel all the way here!
I didn't...
Oh my god, let me grab more buttons.
The CC is insane.
I literally...
They like threw me into like a different dimension.
I was not ready for that.
I was like, where am I?
Alright.
We combo'd Yeah, he combo'd me so fucking hard.
I like traveled to a new area.
Okay, we gotta get rid of...
He's confused!
He stopped moving!
Okay.
Okay, we got...
Come on.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
I parried him.
I don't know there's too many people on my screen.
Like...
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god!
Where am I?
Did I kill him?
I can't tell!
Where are the people?
Alright, I killed another boss.
I killed two bosses.
There we go.
Two bosses with the one hit.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god, please.
He's still fucking praying?!
Oh no.
Oh no!
That's not fair!
Who's letting him pray?!
Alright.
How is he still allowed to pray?!
Oh my god.
Somebody stop him!
Somebody stop him from praying!
That's illegal!
Not the boss in prayers.
Bro!
What am I supposed to do?!
Like, this isn't fair!
I'm trying my best here.
He's praying.
What do you want me to do?
Oh no.
There's like, twisters!
And like, fucking lightning!
I'm punching everybody right now!
Oh no.
Oh, thank god we got 300.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, thank god.
It's just Zhang Jiao now.
I killed all his fucking allies!
It's you and I now!
Oh, fuck, okay.
That's right!
No more praying for you!
Please.
I am killing a fucking god right now.
Just chill.
You're literally fighting minions.
You're just fighting the little guys now.
Fine.
I'm doing like 15 damage.
Wow, everybody else.
Well, he's doing like 100.
Oh, he's so low.
He's so low.
Are you serious?
Are you- AHHHHH!
Okay.
Nice!
Oh, he's so low.
Come on, come on!
Come on!
Oh, I did not mean to get on a horse.
Sorry.
I accidentally got on a horse, but like, that's not what I wanted to do.
It looked cool though, didn't it?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
No!
He got rocked!
He got- He got rocked!
No, that's supposed to be Sun Jian!
Wait!
No!
History has been rewritten!
I can't believe it.
Oh, thank god.
That was so hard.
That was actually a really difficult fight.
Wait, what?
He just got Thanos-stabbed?
Wait, what do you mean he disappeared in thin air?
What do you mean?
Concentrate my bravery to launch a shockwave.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's cool.
I'm gonna boost my bravery then.
Let's go, Walnut!
Let's fucking go!
Okay, nice.
What did I do?
Uh...
Okay, yeah, I won't be able to encourage my horse.
I thought it was- I thought it was trickery.
You mean magic is real?
It's alright.
Lu Bei took Sun Jian's rock.
We'll only exhaust our troops.
Oh.
He will die soon, even if we leave him be.
Not even a doctor of surpassing skill would be able to save him.
Can we just, like, magic his wounds?
But his death must be one of humiliation.
Damn.
You want to?
A hero who died bravely, fighting to the bitter end.
Such a death could very well become the symbol for another uprising.
That's true.
Unless we cut off his head and display it, the Yellow Turbans will rise again.
They just made him a mayor.
Or a matra?
Is that how it's called?
He's not wrong.
Split up and search for Zhang Chao.
Understood?
A martyr?
I don't know how to pronounce a martyr, yeah?
Congratulations, Ziluan.
What does that mean?
I did?
What did I get?
Do you know something?
Yeah, what do you know?
Who is he?
Zhang Chao?
The fuck?
Who is he?
Who the fuck is he?
Can she not be more specific for me?
Have I been here though?
Yeah, I have.
Oh, this is where I started.
I remember now.
Freedom!
Sorry, I'm like obsessed with this.
Alright.
Hello?
I'm told that somebody's waiting for me here.
Oh my god, Zhang Chao!
Is that you?
You look so healthy.
Sakura Blossom means love.
Don't say that.
To help those in need.
But lose your way and you shall be punished by a guardian of peace.
And now...
Tell me.
Where did
I...
I can't fix you.
Woah, woah, woah!
Personal space!
Why wasn't I able to prevent that?
If this is just human nature then there is no way to save this world.
A question.
We humans are not ready to have answered.
I'm sorry, I couldn't fix you.
The great sage Zhang Chao.
The people to dream of peace.
Bro, thousands of people died!
That is not peace.
Dreams can move people.
People can change the world.
There
must be...
Must be what?
Must be one Zhang Chao!
No!
We'll never know!
I'm gonna fucking sleep at night thinking about it!
The eternal cliffhanger.
A what?
That makes me sick to my stomach.
We must learn from Zhang Chao.
Learn what?
What do you mean by that?
Ever since we first fought against the Yellow Turbans I have been thinking.
I believe Zhang Chao was a man of dignity who stood up to help those in suffering.
What a fucking rewrite of like his entire identity.
Carrying a peace kill count of a few thousand.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
We have plenty of time now that the battle is over.
And apparently, there is an official post we'll be needed for here in G.
Oh shit, what a fucking snake, Lu Bei!
Already sneaking up to get promoted.
And me too, the fourth swan brother.
Wait, but what would I do?
Wait, wait a minute.
What about me?
Can't you just disbanded like that?
You were my employer.
Wait, what about me, Lu Bei?
Impatient as ever.
And where is it you intend to go in such a hurry?
Luoyang.
Cao Cao.
You can't be.
Justice has been dealt to Zhang Jiao, the renegade.
It's time to fight.
It's time to pursue Lu Bu, guys.
That is not righteous.
No eyepatch?
He hasn't been shot in the eye yet.
Very soon.
Very, very soon.
I shall pursue him!
No one can stop me!
I'm a little worried though, because that Zhang Jiao fight was a little worrisome.
He's never been that difficult to kill until now.
I'm a little worried that this fucking wizard actually knew magic.
What's wrong, my lord?
I feel like Lu Bu's just gonna press one button and I'm just gonna be dead.
Oh no, he's just gonna bring out his own fucking magic at this point.
But with them gone, where will people's rage and discontent be aimed at now?
He's just gonna look at me and I'm just gonna get a heart attack.
And I'm gonna be like oh my god, what?
Another storm will be brewing soon.
We are the Sun.
The proud blades of the Han.
Whatever the circumstances, we must fulfill our duty as warriors.
Honestly, his horse is gonna touch me and I'm gonna fucking die too.
His horse is just gonna trample me to death before I get to him.
Only that I am a guardian.
I can read the winds?
How fucking...
How fucked up is this instance?
That's some strong ass instance.
...
And how did I...
Yeah, am I the last one?
Me and her?
I will end the bloodline with me.
...
Wait, I'm not him?
Wait, I'm not the main... You can't just tell me that right now I'm not the main...
I'm not the main... A true... Okay.
A true hero.
I'm not the main character.
I am not the main character?!
I need to find Zhaoyun, guys.
Koei has managed to squeeze Zhaoyun in here.
I gotta find Zhaoyun.
They're like, you thought you were the main character?
It's time for you to find Zhaoyun.
Hello?
Oh my god, is she hot?
How hot?
Oh, it's like a memory.
I thought it was a different girl.
What's wrong?
Can't believe I'm not the main...
I swear to god, if they try to make me find Zhaoyun, I swear... That is so...
I feel like I'm sitting in a chair.
After all that, it's always Zhaoyun.
After all that, it's always him.
It's always him!
Yes, please.
I'm never the main character.
That's basically the Flurry Kingdoms era.
Chapter 2.
Dong Zhuo's treachery in the capital.
The lords answered Cao Cao's call and assembled.
We have a time skip before the next...
the famous Do Not Pursue Lu Bu.
That's okay, you're our favorite NPC cast.
Thank you, Lucifer cast.
Thank you, thank you.
The world is becoming a dangerous place.
Professional soldiers have been kept busy, to say the least.
We appreciate your service.
Ah, I almost forgot.
I came to bring you your letters.
Who knows, maybe some wealthy lords... Oh my god, my super chat!
Well, if you have anything to ask me, now's a good time to do it.
Letters for me?
Yes, a few arrived while you were away.
Oh my god, I have a backlog of super chats, guys.
Just like real life.
Alright, uh...
Where are the good jobs?
The volunteer army has disbanded, so now you need a new source of income.
Is that right?
Well, let's see.
The lords of the land are always recruiting.
That's true, they're always hiring mercenaries and stuff.
Here's a letter.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
I don't have anything else to ask.
Alright, guys.
It's time to do super chat reading.
I read my letters from ye olde ancient China times.
Alright, how many?
Only two?!
After everything I did.
And one of them is just from Lupe.
Not Doki.
Yellow Turban Soldier, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I do not know if you remember me, but I was a child who tried to steal to take care of my ill father and was almost cut down by an official.
That child is now a member of the Yellow Turbans, fighting to change the world.
Now the time has come for me to face you alongside Chang'e.
To be completely truthful, I've already seen you in battle many times.
The warrior with the piercing gaze threatening my comrades, but I wasn't scared.
After all, you're my hero.
I don't think you'll recognize me when we next meet, so I want to tell you how thankful I am while I can.
It's because of you that I was able to live my own convictions, and I have no regret.
I think I killed this Dragoon.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty...
He was one of the 300 soldiers I killed during that fight.
He's probably dead.
He probably is.
Okay, Lu Bei, how have you been faring?
I'm busy as always.
My days are largely spent rushing from place to place.
I'm here in Yu Province now, and thoughts of you...
Whoa!
Whoa, Lu Bei.
I'm gonna use the bathroom after I got steamy, Lu Bei.
Whoa!
Alright, I'll be right back.
I need to use the bathroom.
Back.
While I'm not certain what prompted these thoughts...
While I am not certain what prompted...
Who wrote this?
Okay, they know what they're doing.
While I am not certain what prompted these thoughts, I am certain that Guan Yin and Zhang Fei miss you just as much as I do.
Our world is a dangerous place.
What should we ever be...
What should we ever be fortunate enough to meet again?
We must make it another time to remember.
What do you throw?
I can't even read this seriously.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
No homo though.
No homo.
This is...
Bro, what kind of letter am I fucking...
I don't know.
What kind of letter am I reading?
Literally all...
Oh my god.
I can't.
I don't...
They knew what they were doing.
Oh my god.
They knew exactly what they were doing.
He's playing Dynasty Warriors Origin on stream while playing the nasty Warriors in your head.
Thank you for superchatting.
Just really good roommates.
Many thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
This isn't a letter.
This is a booty call.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Wow.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I was not...
He's fucking wild.
Oh my god.
He's so wild.
I'm not...
I'm not okay right now.
That was actually a wild thing I read today.
Alright.
In both history and the novel, the three sworn brothers all slept in the same bed at times.
I'm just saying.
Candid, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Atlas, thank you for the superchat.
I forgot to add the homo in the end.
Or did they?
Thank you for the superchat, Atlas.
Thank you.
Fudgetop, thank you for the superchat.
Just really good roommates, guys!
Just incredibly good roommates, everybody.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh, I am definitely not level 12.
Oh my god.
Sorry, that like actually...
I'm so sorry.
Alright.
I was just not ready.
I was not ready today.
There's been some wild shit going on.
Okay, let's get rid of all the low level spheres.
It's just been wild.
What can I say?
It's just been pretty wild.
Vitality pill.
Oh man.
Sometimes people need a little bit of help, okay?
I would do attack, honestly.
I'll grab the attack.
Alright.
Yeah, definitely bring some of those.
I'll put the strength pill in.
I still like a 48.
There you go.
Guys, it was not like this.
I swear to god, it was not like this before.
Guys.
Guys, the previous Dynasty Warriors was definitely less suggestive.
Guys, I swear to god.
I...
I swear to god.
This...
This has been pretty wild.
Alright, suppression of Yu province.
The traitor Chongchong has caused an uprising in your province.
Quell the rebellion with Liu Bei.
But the novel!
The novel did have some romance in there.
Oh.
Thanks, Liu Bei.
That sentence could have been rewritten a different way.
You could have been like, I'm glad you arrived.
You know what's crazy?
Gonfey is actually an aristocrat and he's really fucking rich.
But instead, he lets Lu Bei be poor.
Real bros.
Oh Yeah, not aristocrat he's uh, he's He's a butcher.
Sorry.
Yeah, he's a butcher.
Not aristocrat.
He was a butcher and so he was like he was incredibly rich.
I feel like butchers would make a lot because like, uh, food is always scarce and stuff and meat was expensive back then.
Okay.
Okay, but as I mentioned before, we're still unaware of Wuhan's movement.
That's fine.
This is why I want not Doki and Guan Yu to move freely around the battlefield.
Okay, so I can just go wherever they want.
Very well.
I can handle this myself.
I don't need no Guan Yu.
He's just gonna oh wait JK.
Oh wait JK.
JK.
I can be Guan Yu.
Never mind.
I don't want Never mind.
I won't be Guan Yu.
Never mind.
I didn't realize I could be him.
Come with me Guan Yu.
All right, how do I become him again, I don't remember.
Wait, how do I become him guys?
I forgot.
I forgot how to...
Why the fuck would I have to be the non-main character?
I want to be a guy that become a guy.
Now moving towards the summit.
Oh my god, how do I become you?
I want to become you!
Oh Only for a little while.
What's the point?
What what the fuck is the point?
What's the point if I can't be Guan Yu?
What's the point?
Oh shit, that is cool.
It truly is pain.
Alright, let's get rid of these guys.
Wait, why are you running away?
Why are you already running away like a cow?
That's fucking right.
Your friends ran.
That's right, he watched you run!
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna pursue them.
I ain't no coward!
You coward, Lupe!
Keep going!
Well, there's an empty area in front of me, I wonder what's gonna happen over there.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit.
It's okay, I'm okay.
Nice.
Broke his thing.
Come on, you think you're good at this game?
I am not!
I am an NPC, but I'm still better than you.
Wait, what?
Wheels.
Wheels are dual-wielded weapons.
Oh, I got a new weapon.
Oh my god, this is my favorite weapon!
This is actually my favorite weapon.
This was my favorite weapon back when the game first came out.
Or like, Dynasty Warriors 2.
It's actually the best weapon.
Wait.
It's her weapon.
Yeah, it's Sun Shan Shan's weapon.
We'll make those worms regret invading our land.
Oh no, is it wartime?
Oh no.
Oh, that's a lot of people!
Okay, let's grab it.
What's the power level though?
Oh, it's 45?
I'll use it just cuz I can right now.
I'll just use it just cuz I can.
I normally wouldn't because like...
Because my other one is just so much stronger, so...
Nice.
Wait, what?
Oh, nice.
Oh, it looks so cool though.
Oh, it looks so cool!
It looks so cool!
Oh my god, look at it go!
Wait, how do I become Guan Yun again, guys?
Lord Gongsun Zan will soon be in grave danger.
You must go to his aid before the enemy surrounds him.
Let it rip.
Let it fucking rip!
That's great!
Spin!
Oh shit!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I didn't realize.
Oh, I forgot about our commander.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I'm heading over.
Oh, I forgot about our commander.
Opportunity to fight back with our own might.
Oh, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading- oh shit!
Oh, I'm out!
Oh, my god, stop!
Okay, that was awkward.
That was actually awkward.
We have come to provide reinforcements.
Turn the table.
Nice.
That was like a fucking- It was like a fucking- like a wave.
Yeah, I need to go this way.
I need help.
Sorry guys, I need to go help.
All right, look, I gotta help, like, the main guy.
Guys, I- Look, it's fine as long as our main commander is alive.
That's fine.
Oh, please, please.
I'm- I need to make sure these guys are okay first.
Okay, wait.
All right, we have to figure out these guys first.
Oh, I can beat him!
What fun is this?
Okay, let me get rid of him first.
Wait, actually, I wanted- I don't mean to use him yet.
I don't waste him on these guys.
These guys are nothing but nobodies.
Oh my god, please, I don't- Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Changing characters.
Fuck it, we gotta do this fast.
We gotta play a real hero now.
We can finally be the main character.
That's fucking right.
Wait.
That's right.
I am the main character for real now.
Okay, noobie, look, I- Please, please, I- I can't be everywhere.
Oh no.
Yeah, he does a lot of fucking damage.
Holy shit.
He- oh my god.
All right, nice.
Okay, I'm done.
But like, I'm still go- wait, how do I cancel this?
Oh fuck.
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay.
I didn't mean to do that.
Look, they were all dead.
I couldn't do anything else.
Okay, guys.
They were all dead.
Like, what was I supposed to do?
All right, uh, wait, I cannot change?
Okay, I'm gonna go back to this sword, cuz uh...
Because it's stronger.
I'd love to use the spin, but like, the other weapon is just- are you serious?
Are you serious?
There's another guy heading over?
Oh no.
Oh, I'm cheering up.
Cheer, cheer, cheer, cheer, cheer.
Oh my god, there's too many people!
I'm stuck, Gwon-Yoon!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Sorry, I gotta- I'm freaking- I'm freaking out right now.
I'm actually- I'm freaking out.
Oh my god, and I have to go back to save- I have to go back to save the general after too!
Please!
Like, I can't do everything!
Oh my god, please.
Okay, I hope Gwon-Yoon is like, helping me out.
Like, I-
I hope he's helping, I- I feel like I'm doing everything myself right now.
So I hope he's helping out right now, honestly.
That's fucking right.
Alright, thank god.
I don't know what Gwon-Yoon is doing, but he better be fucking doing enough.
Alright, Gwon-Yoon, let's get this general.
Alright, this is looking a little rough though.
Not gonna lie, it is looking a little rough.
Okay, okay, now- now we have to go back!
Alright, back we go!
Back we go!
We gotta go back, because our leader needs help again!
We gotta go back!
Oh my god!
Alright, here we go again!
Off we go!
Oh my god.
Okay, right here.
Okay, we're fine.
Look, I've been through a lot, alright?
Buddy, I- You're like, no but- I defeated a fucking wizard, you think you're like- you think I care about you?
I literally killed a wizard today!
He threw rocks!
He was an actual earthbender!
I thought they were- I thought magic- I didn't believe in magic, but then now- Now I'm a believer after what I saw today.
You're not him.
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted to do.
I was trying to press- I wanted to press Y, but it's alright.
I can kill him now.
Nice.
Okay, there's one more officer.
Alright, we just gotta get him.
Alright, get over here- oh shit!
Wait, did he parry me?!
Oh shit!
He can do that?!
Okay, nice.
I got my insane sword now.
Wait, what?
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, stranger danger!
Whoa!
I have no idea what he was trying to do, but he- that scared me.
Wait, he was the boss?!
Oh shit!
Oh, I did it!
Nice.
I didn't even know he was the main guy.
Oh, it was a command grab!
Thank you.
Thank you, Guardian.
That's me!
But yeah, why am I not the main character?
Thank you!
Enables wheel recovery in mid-air?
Oh, that's cool.
That looks cool.
Nice.
Alright.
We have more bravery now.
Nice.
Okay, uh... Restores to a set amount upon reach.
Okay, we definitely need that.
Uh, I'm gonna max out this first.
Okay, you two has died.
You two lost to the small guys.
Guardian, I had to fucking run back and forth.
You got your butt kicked.
Nice.
We did such a good job, guys, right?
I said, no match for us.
Gamrage, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
That's good to know.
But all of these are rejections.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Well, that's good to know.
And then, zero reply.
Okay, I'll do like... Yeah, that's cool.
True, that's cool.
I'm just playing hard to get, guys.
I want them to want me.
I'm just being elusive.
Whoa!
Oh, whoa!
Whoa.
Oh, I always have time for you, Guardian.
It's time.
We've unlocked a new route.
My heart.
This dating sim is winning me over.
Perhaps so.
Guys, do you guys feel this tension between me and Guan Yu right now?
Yeah.
Therefore, I need a great leader to whom I can dedicate my efforts.
In that, I am lucky indeed to have Liu Bei.
My only worry is that his ambitions are so great that they might overpower my imagination entirely.
Does he have what it takes?
I'm not s- Aw, man.
He's not.
He's so mediocre.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm sorry.
He's such a mediocre leader.
Well, I guess you just gotta convince me, Guan Yu.
I'm sorry.
Toki, no.
Then, let's keep talking.
I feel they're both the same, but which one's more rowdy?
Which one would Guan Yu like more?
But yeah, I found myself wanting to talk more.
Oh my god, Guan Yu.
I feel like anything I say is not as bad as the official...
Choices.
Like, the official choices are like...
The official choices feel so much worse.
Wow!
Okay.
What?!
They just cut it like that?!
What just happened?!
Oh my god!
What the fuck just happened?!
He wanted to etch my face and my voice so he could remember it before I left!
What
just happened?!
Maybe he pursued you.
Oh my god!
Why did they just cut it like that?!
Why did they just stop?
Oh my god!
The scene ends there?!
Unfortunately, if I was for a while, I wouldn't have this as something to remember me by.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna call it there.
That was a wild scene.
That was actually fucking wild.
I don't think I... Guys, I'm...
Guys, I don't think... I don't think... That was wild.
That was actually fucking wild.
I can't... I need to rest up after that.
I'm just fucking around.
But the official dialogue and the official cutscenes are so much worse than anything I can say.
And it catches me off guard every time.
Oh my god.
It catches me off guard every time they say that.
Raze, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know until right now that Dynasty Warriors was real like that.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you, Raze.
Oh my god.
Nexy, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe how bad that got.
I was joking and then it just got so much worse.
Oh my god.
Bro, the fucking people who translated this knew exactly what they were doing.
They knew exactly what they were doing.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, finally.
I've always wanted the romance in Romance in the Three Kingdoms.
I always, I've always wanted this.
That's what we were missing out on, guys.
It's what we've been missing out this entire time.
Oh my god.
Zekra, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
10 out of 10 stories.
Thank you for the superchat.
Atlas, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it's just bromance, guys.
It's just bromance, everybody.
Well, I think this was a good... I think this was a good part to call it, guys.
I think that cutscene between me and Guan Yin...
I don't know if I could keep going after that.
I think that was the highest note I could end.
We still have yet to pursue... We still have yet to pursue Lu Bu, but like...
I'm too... I think that was the highest note I could end on.
I...
That really...
What a way to end.
Oh my god.
Yeah, so okay.
I'll be posting my schedule tonight, because...
Alright, so it was actually... It's a collab with Doobie, but she couldn't do it this week.
So we're gonna be doing it next week or the week after, because I'm...
I don't know if I'm gonna be available next week.
But we're gonna be doing Marvel Rivals with Doobie either next week or the week after.
So that was a collab that we were trying to arrange.
But yes, so this week, there's no collabs this week.
But it's either next week or the week after with Doobie.
Anyway...
Yeah, it's just me and Doobie duoing.
And I'll be playing DPS, because I'll be playing on an alt account.
Because I think she's like... She's like gold, right?
I think she's gold right now.
I asked her what her rank is.
And she said she's gold at the moment.
So I'll most likely be playing DPS on like a silver account or something.
Ani, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't wait to see how the Pursuit of Lubu will go now.
Guys, that's not what it means!
That's not what Pursuit of Lubu does not mean that.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I guess, shielding-wise...
If you guys...
The merch for my concert pre-order stuff ends next week.
So, you know...
Pre-order your concert merch before it's gone forever.
Even if you didn't go to the concert, you can still pre-order the merch.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here now.
As always everybody, that was a fun time.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
You stand up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
What a fucking wild game.
I swear the other Dynasty Warriors are like...
Never gone to that level before.
Whoever wrote the English translations...
Know exactly what they're doing.
Because I've never seen Dynasty Warriors...
Get...
The bromance...
Get this...
Like...
Intense.
Alright.
Bye everybody.
Bye.